. Hello, mission! Hallo München!
Warum seid ihr so gut drauf?
Ist es der Nebel?
Warum rastet ihr so aus?
Es ist schon der Nebel, oder?
Chef Artitze, meine Damen und Herren!
Florentin Will!
Ist im Haus!
München!
Du bist da! Und du bist auch da! Ich sehe niemanden! Vielleicht müssen wir evakuieren, wir wissen es noch nicht. Wow, wow. Seien erst mal die Türen auf, glaube ich. Lieben Gruss an München und an alle Epileptiker im Raum. Ey, wir hatten uns vorgenommen, so lustig, ulgig, wir nehmen uns an der Hand, wir laufen auf die Bühne, ich habe gar nichts mehr gesehen. Seit WK2 war das ein Blindflug einfach. Du hast mir noch Sachen gesagt, von wegen man muss wie eine Banane einlaufen, weil du das in der Theater AG so gelernt hast, habe ich alles schon wieder vergessen. Das habe ich da, das ist ein Pfeil und ab da war ich blind. Es war eine sehr schöne Banane, finde ich, aber wir hatten noch nie Haze auf der Bühne, also für alle, die es nicht wissen, der geneigtes Entertainment-Show-Business-Meister sagt Haze dazu, wozu ihr normales Folgen Nebel, wie man auch sagt. Es funktioniert gut, ich finde es funktioniert sehr gut, es ist natürlich ein grosser Vorteil, dass wir euch nicht sehen müssen. Das hilft auf jeden Fall. Nein, wir freuen uns natürlich, wir sind froh in München zu sein sein in minger aus meiner ist das so ein trigger word hier eigentlich bei münchen haben alle ignoriert hast du minger gesagt wir sind ausgeführt nein nein du ich komme aus münchen servus christi ja es gibt korrechtsbirnach gott das seit ein seit zwei tagen versucht er diesen satz zu sagen es Es gibt kein schlechtes Bier nicht, weil jeder Bierbrauer versucht, ein gutes Bier zu bauen.
Ne, kein Bier, das war ein Spaß.
Ich habe Steffen mal davon erzählt, wie ein Freund von mir, der hat einen Nachbarn und der haut immer wichtige Theorien raus. So ein catchy, das startete Anekdote. Es ist ein Freund und der hat einen Nachbarn und von dem hat der Onkel und ist ja auch jetzt. Also ein Kumpel von mir hat mal bei Skype aus Versehen jemanden angerufen, der nicht anrufen wollte, der hat dann von seiner Putzvor erzählt, die Nachbarn. Wie der Onkel an Weihnachten, der immer zu weit ausholt und man sagt, ach nee. Und der hat mal die These aufgestellt, dass es ja kein schlechtes Bier geben kann. Ja, es gibt kein schlechtes Bier. Das haben Leute hier verstanden. Ja, aber ich fand die Begründung einfach wasserdicht, es kann kein schlechtes Bier geben, weil jeder Bierbrauer versucht ja ein gutes Bier zu brauen. Ja. Also es gibt ja keinen Bierbrauer, der morgens aufsteht und sagt, heute mal ein schlechtes. Ja. Heute mal ein von diesen riesen Kesseln, diesen riesen Kesseln. Aber nach der Logik gibt es auch keine schlechte Mathe-Klausur, weil kein… Ja, ich habe die Bildsleitung gelesen. Das ist ein heikles Thema hier. War das nur in Bayern so oder wurde überall demonstriert? Also diese Petition? Nee, die bayerischen Abiturienten haben sich beschwert, dass die Mathe-Prüfung so schwer war. Oh nein! Das haben wir noch gar nicht durchgenommen. Das können nicht alle studieren. Oh nein! Oh nein! Keine Textaufgabe! Oh nein, die Losbude war so schwer. Es ging wirklich um eine Losbude. Losbude? Um eine Losbude in der Stochastikaufgabe. War das eine Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung? Ja, genau, da musste man dann ausrechnen, für wie viel Geld muss die ihre Lose anbieten, damit sie Gewinn macht. Und was war die Lösung? Ach, nee, die Lose kostet nicht der Einkaufspreis von dem Hauptgewinn, so was in Richtung, glaube ich, acht Euro war der, ich weiss nicht genau. Hatte jemand Abitur geschrieben und fand es auch so schwierig? Ja, erste Reihe, nicht so schwer. Nee, war nur ein ganz kurz, war eine Oderfrage, also du hast nicht geschrieben, du hast doch geschrieben und fand es nicht so schwer, war machbar, war die Losaufgabe kompliziert gestellt, was war das Problem, kein Problem, du bist einfach so,, wie stehst du in Mathe, wie viele Punkte hast du in Mathe? Das ist schon lange hergebildet. Ja, okay, da bist du, ich will auch. Wir sind nicht in Topical Island, wir sind in der Late-to-the-party-Episode. Aber ich fand es interessant, weil woran man sehen kann, dass die bayerischen Abiturienten nicht so gut in Mathe sind, daran, dass die Petition von mehr Leuten unterschrieben wurde, als es Abiturienten gibt. Ah, jaja.
Also da merkt man schon, Zahlen ist nicht die Stärke, das funktioniert nicht so ganz.
Aber ich wünsche euch natürlich alles viel Glück, dass sie am Ende dann …
Dass sie gewinnt.
Da gibt es dann nochmal so einen Plus oben dazu.
Ich fand, die war sehr schön formuliert, diese Aufgabe, also diese Petition,
wirklich den Anforderungen der Schüler, des Lehrplans, also sehr viel Genitiv, wo ich dachte, Respekt ey, in Deutsch war bestimmt alles okay soweit. Bei Stefan muss man nur zwei Genitiva verwenden und schon hat man ihn sofort in der Tasche. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Da weiss man sofort, wovor man ist. Stefan ist sehr leicht zu beeindrucken. Ich bin sehr leicht zu beeindrucken, Genitiv reicht für, ich komme. Ich dachte ja eigentlich, dass mindestens fünfzig jubilige Leute in diesem Graben stehen, den wir heute haben.
Keiner.
Wir haben gesagt, wir würden hier heute Abend gerne einen Liveauftritt machen, haben uns gefragt, wollt ihr einen Panzergraben gegen die Zuschauer und wir haben, wie man das im Flugzeug kennt.
Schon.
Warum nicht?
Wir wollten erst nein sagen, aber wir haben beim Aussprechen gemerkt, dass wir uns versprechen. Wie beim Flieger immer, wenn die Fragen, hätten sie gerne, die fragen die immer, so Käsesandwich oder Salamis-Sandwich. Ich überlege in meinem Kopf, wenn man sich sagen würde, ich sage immer das Falsche. Ich überlege zu lange und sage dann das Falsche, Salami, Käse, na dammit, und dann nimmt man es da einfach. Ja, ich versuche ja auch jetzt in München wieder anzukommen, so als Exil-Münchener eigentlich oder Exilil Bayer und es ist sehr anstrengend, ich muss mich sehr konzentrieren, Richtige zu sagen und ich sage es eigentlich immer falsch, ich dachte immer, man sagt Wiederschauen, stimmt aber nicht, man sagt trotzdem Wiedersehen und ich sage trotzdem jedes Mal Wiedersehen und dann sagt die andere Person Wiedersehen, dann sage ich, ah nee, Wiedersehen und es funktioniert überhaupt gar nicht und es funktioniert überhaupt gar nicht. Was dann so klingt für die andere Person, als ob du dich auf gar keinen Fall wiedersehen willst. Auch das, oder als ob ich die Person korrigiert hätte. Dann gibt die mir hier ihre Hirnwurst oder so und dann sage ich, ja, wieder schauen, wiedersehen, wiedersehen, einfach so. Okay, machen wir es bis du gesagt. Es funktioniert nicht. Aber ist es nicht manchmal so, dass wenn nicht genug Leute kommen, schiebt man die Bühne nach vorne? Ja. Du, eigentlich wären wir da hinten gewesen. Stimmt. Damit es nicht so aussieht, dass Plätze nicht verkauft wurden, habe ich irgendwo mal gehört. Damit es nicht so aussieht, dass wir Plätze nicht verkauft wurden, schiebt man dann die Bühne so vor. Macht man da nicht so Molton-Vorhänge? Sieht man die nicht so quer durch die Reihen? Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht. Also es kann gut sein, dass hier einfach noch so eine Panzerbarrikade hinzugefügt wurde, weil keine Tickets verkauft wurden. Kann gut sein. Schade. Aber du hast ein paar Tage hier schön verbracht. Ich habe schön... Ich hätte was wie ihm gesagt. Nein, nein, nein, nein, ich habe hier schön ein paar Tage im schönen Minger im Hotelzimmer verbracht, es war herrlich. Im Hotelzimmer. Es war wunderschön. Ich hatte einen Fernseher mit allen Fernsehprogrammen der Welt. Ja. sehr interessant, weil ich bin ja so ein Zapper. Ich bin ja ein Nach-Unten-Zapper. Ich glaube, es gibt zwei verschiedene Zapper, der, der nach oben zappt und der, der nach unten zappt. Ich glaube, man kann die Menschheit genau einteilen in zwei Gruppen. Die einen zappen, zapp up und zapp down. Und so kann man die gesamte Bevölkerung erschliessen. Ich könnte mir auch nie vorstellen, irgendwie eine langfristige Beziehung mit jemandem einzugehen, der Zap-up ist. So, für mich Zap-down. Das Programm geht bei null los, dann will ich doch als erstes wissen, was ist Zap-down. Nee, ich mache Zap-up und höre dann auf, weil dazu Zap-up bin, ich bei Al Jazeera angekommen bin. Ja, das stimmt. Das ist der Sender, wo ich sage, so, ja, also was kommt nach Al Jazeera, wo ich jetzt Bock habe, schön zu gucken, schön zwei Stunden, so einzuschlafen. Ja, es ist schwierig. Es gibt wahnsinnig viele Fernsehsender, es ist unglaublich. Es ist wahnsinnig viele polnische Fernsehsender, meine Herren, unglaublich. Denkt man gar nicht. Ähnliches Programm, sehr viel, Mann vor Wetterkarte redet polnisch, das scheint da wahnsinnig gut anzukommen. Sehr beliebt, ja. Also da gibt es, glaube ich, 200 Formate, die einfach sagen, ich habe eine Idee, pass auf, Freunde. Wetterkarte redet Polnisch, das scheint da wahnsinnig gut anzukommen. Sehr beliebt, ja. Also da gibt es glaube ich 200 Formate, die einfach sagen, ich habe eine Idee, pass auf Freunde. Wetterkarte, ja, ja, ja, jetzt pass auf, jetzt kommt es. Mann steht davor, ja, steht davor, nicht der Mann, davor, davor spricht Polnisch. Das ist genau das, was wir suchen. Ja, ja, wirklich. Es funktioniert, also falls ihr mal einen Nebenjob braucht, geht nach Polen und verkauft Fernsehformate, es funktioniert. Oder du hast so eine Soap geschaut, die halt bei Leuten spielt, die Wetterkarten vortragen. Das stimmt natürlich auch, das ist natürlich ein beliebter Soap-Plot. Wie Newsroom, nur so Meteorologen halt. Das stimmt, das ist für mich sehr schwer zu unterscheiden, ob das jetzt eine fiktive Nachrichtensendung oder eine… Weil du die Sprachen nicht verstanden hast. Das stimmt, vielleicht habe ich jetzt auch ein paar Fans von der polnischen Serie gespoilert, dass er am Ende tatsächlich seinen Job bekommt als Nachrichtensprecher. Und jetzt sind die ganzen, na gut, jetzt müsste man clever sein, jetzt müsste man irgendwie so Game of... Ne. Manchmal muss man einsehen, da ist kein Gag. Ne, manchmal funktioniert es einfach nicht. Nicht mal Oliver Welke hätte sich ein Gag einfallen lassen können. Bist du Game of Thrones-Fan? Ist ein grosses Thema, muss man auch drüber reden. Ist ein ganz heikles Thema, ist glaube ich das zweite Bean-Nest, in das wir heute ... Oh, das ist ja auch schon ein Spoiler gewesen. Bean-Nest? Also nichts, ich habe nicht gesagt, dass ein Bean-Nest in der letzten Folge vorkam. Jetzt hast du gerade, dass kein Beanennest vorkommt. Stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, ich nehme das nochmal zurück. Ich sage nicht, dass Bienennester vorkommen, sage aber auch nicht, dass keine Bienennester vorkommen. Ich habe nichts zum Thema Bienennester, Game of Thrones und Staffelfinale gesagt. Ich fand das so weird, die Schauspielerin von I.R. Stark war ja bei Jimmy Fallon. Und dann haben die im 1. April diesen Gag gemacht, dass sie sagt, sie stirbt. Und dann haben die das lange durchgezogen und sie hat so getan, als wäre das ein Spoiler gewesen und ist das ganz aufgelöst, weil das darf sie ja nicht machen, ist rausgerannt und dann kam sie wieder rein und meinte April Fools, ich sterbe nicht und das Publikum hat gesagt, oh cool, aber hey, aber das ist ein fucking Spoiler. Das stimmt eigentlich auch, ja. Also was war jetzt der Witz und hätte das Publikum nicht dann reagieren müssen wie, what the fuck? Ja, noch schlimmer. Ja, das ist doch schlimmer. Aber wenn sie jetzt dann wirklich stirbt, dann ist es natürlich Doppel-Gings. Ja, aber, ja. Es ist super schwierig. Man kommt ja nicht mehr raus. Tatsächlich, mich interessieren ja Spoiler gar nicht so sehr, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Mir ist es relativ egal, ob ich gespoiert werde oder nicht. Es hilft mir oft, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, Spoiler helfen mir oft die Geschichte besser zu verstehen. Man muss sich ganz ehrlich sagen, weil ich relativ häufig nach vielen Folgen Game of Thrones sah, sah, sah und so. Ja, ja, ja, ja. Und der Drache ist jetzt tot, ne? Und jetzt, ah, der mit dem Bart, der hat immer die guten Ideen, oder? Nee, der ist von den Bösen, ja, ja, klar. Ja, ja, stimmt, falls du Spoiler hast, immer her damit. Es hilft mir. Wir haben ja neulich noch über Starbucks gesprochen und deren lustige Marketingstrategie, und jetzt haben sie es wirklich übertrieben, fand ich. Wer? Starbucks hat einen Becher bei Game of Thrones untergebracht. Ja, schon ein Starbucks, das hast du nicht mitbekommen. Ja, es stimmt. Stand auf dem Tisch. Ist ein Spoiler? Ja, vielleicht ein Spoiler. Ich finde es lustig, wenn da so falsch Daenerys falsch geschrieben draufsteht auf dem Star-Bucks-Becher. Das ist gut, das ist nicht schlecht. Gut, das ist nur nicht ein Anweis. Sie haben schon viele die Folge nicht gesehen, tatsächlich. Ja, vielleicht. Die lassen Sie eher noch spoilern. Vielleicht ist das auch in Bayern kein grosses Thema, Game of Thrones. Ich, nee, was hast du dir geguckt? Schwarzwaldklinik.
Äh, die ...
Ich weiss nicht mehr genau, ob der schwarz hat.
Unser Charlie?
Ja, ja, kenn ich, mit dem Äffchen.
Kommt wahnsinnig gut an, Bayern.
Sprechende Affe.
War das eigentlich immer nur ein Affe, oder haben die einfach hinten so ein LKW voller Äffchen gehabt?
Nee, nee, nee, alle Krebs, alle Krebs, zwei Tage am Set, Krebs vom Rotlicht, zack, tot.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, dieses Catering, ich weiss ja nicht, was du so einem Affen füttern sollst. Dann gibst du ihm hier so eine Leona. Weiss man gar nichts drüber, ne? Weiss man gar nichts drüber. Da ist das Wissen komplett weg. Ich hätte wirklich keine Ahnung, der ist ja auch kein, die holen ihn vom Schwarzmarkt oder so, vom Zoll, der durfte nicht eingeführt werden, Movie Star, Tod, Krebs, Leona.
Wie verzollt man so einen Movie Star Affen?
Ich weiss es nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Ich glaube, die haben sich gar keine Mühe gemacht, dem den Text richtig beizubringen, sondern einfach geguckt, welcher von den Affen natürlicherweise das macht.
Man hat sich enttäuscht, wenn die mit dem Text vor ihm sassen und er hat nichts wiederholt.
Tatsächlich, aber es ist meine Jugend, ich habe immer bei meiner Oma viel Fernsehen geschaut, die auch in Bayern wohnt, und ich habe hauptsächlich gesehen, unser Charlie und Kommissar Rex, das heisst, ich bin aufgewachsen als Kind mit der Einstellung, dass ein grosser Teil der Probleme der Menschheit durch Tiere gelöst wird, einfach so. Also alles, was unser Charlie nicht macht, macht Kommissar Rex. Und andersrum, komischerweise bin ich aufgewachsen mit dem Wunsch, Schauspieler zu werden, obwohl ich eigentlich immer nur Tiere gesehen habe. Vielleicht weil du Zeit mit Tieren verbringen willst. Das stimmt schon, ja, ich weiss gar nicht. Oder als polnischer Moderator auf dem Wettergarten stehen will. Das wäre so grossartig, das wäre wirklich fantastisch. Es ist schwer, sich neue Sachen im Fernsehen auszudenken, so jetzt gibt es dann immer neue Krimiserie. Warum, also ich meine, gibt es ein Pferd, gibt es ein mordlösendes Pferd? Nee, ich glaub nicht, bin mir nicht sicher. Warum wurde das nicht weitergeführt, diese Tiere, lösende Verbrechen, das ist ein geniales System eigentlich. Warum wurde das nicht weitergeführt? Man hat es ja tatsächlich jetzt ganz clever gemacht, what the fuck, da hat ein Kino. Siehst du das? Das ist super, die Champions League läuft hinten, wie geil ist das denn? Ich dachte, ich verpasse heute Tottenham gegen Ajax und ich dachte mir, das kriege ich unmöglich hin. Ich wollte schon mein Handy hier hinlegen, es läuft da hinten einfach eine Leinwand. Perfekt. Bisschen distracting, muss ich sagen. Ja, ne, ist okay. Bei Kinderserien wurde es durchgespielt so ein bisschen. Es gibt ja die, wie heissen die nochmal, diese Airplanes, die jetzt die Fälle lösen und so weiter, dann gibt es die Hunde, Paw Patrol, die Fälle lösen, da müssen mittlerweile alles Fälle, bei den Tieren ist man schon durch und hat das Gegenstände, die Fälle lösen. Pflanzen ist halt ein bisschen schwierig. Und alles ist auf dieser Grundformel von den Power Rangers aufgebaut. Es gibt halt verschiedenfarbige, oft dann auch mal noch das Mädchen, der Baumeister zum Beispiel, der Baumeister hatte auch das Mädchenbagger und alle anderen Bagger und so und dann am Ende können die sich zu einem Superbagger zusammen formen und es gibt immer diesen einen, der den ganzen Leuten sagt, wo sie zu baggern haben und am Ende kann man das alles als ein Spielzeug kaufen. Ja. Bob, der war der. Ja, stimmt. Und Paw Patrol ist glaube ich sogar von dem Macher von Bob der Baumeister, der hat einfach eine Formel irgendwann und hat sich überlegt, so mache ich es jetzt immer. Und Kinder sind so doof, die fallen halt immer drauf rein. Aber was kommt als nächstes? Wir hatten jetzt Tiere, jetzt kommen Flugzeuge, Fahrzeuge. Schwierig. Pflanzen ist halt ein bisschen schwierig, weil sie sich nicht bewegen können. Die müssen dann immer erst, da wo dann der Mord passiert, müssen sie ihre Pollen erstmal hinstreuen, damit da die nächste wächst. Und das dauert ja auch, zumindest zwei Jahre, bis da wieder was wächst. Ja, ja, das stimmt schon. Also die Staffel zwei von Plants hat sich echt gezogen, muss man sagen. Weißt du, was ich gelernt habe jetzt auch über München? Nein. Die haben ja in ihren Biergärten einen gewissen Baum, sag mal, ja gut, gelernt ist ein grosses Wort, okay? Ich habe einen Baum gesehen. Aufgeschnappt. So, hab ich bescheuert, wie heißt der Baum denn? Kastanie, so Kastanie, so Kastanie, so. Wie viele Baumarten gibt es und wie groß ist die Chance, dass er jetzt recht hatte, der Kastanienrufer? Es ist glaube ich wirklich schon eine Kastanie und die Idee der Kastanie ist, dass deren Blätter, wenn die auf dem Boden fallen, sorgen die Blätter dafür, dass da nichts anderes mehr wachsen kann. Und deswegen ist es so gut für Biergärten, damit du halt dann nicht immer den ganzen Scheiss von unten hast, die dann dann halt irgendwie da so kommen. Aber was ist bei Kastanienblätter? Ja, und die sagen einfach, nee, wo ich bin, ist sonst niemand. Warum ist es gut für Biergärten? Weil du nicht willst, dass irgendwie so ein Löwenzahn die unten in die Hose wächst oder so. Aber du willst, dass alles wo der Scheiss Kastanienblätter ist oder was? Ja, also ich habe in meinem Leben noch nie ein Bier getrunken, was weiß ich, was man da für Möglichkeiten sagt, ich will weichen Untergrund und schattiges Plätzchen. Nee, ist ja schön. Ich weiss nicht. Ich fand's so gut, dass es einfach von allen Pflanzen der Welt eine Arschlochpflanze gibt, der einfach ganz klar sagt, Freunde, hier bin ich und dürfen wir hier wachsen? Nee, dürft ihr nicht. Und dann werfen die ihre Blätter da drauf. Ich finde die Vorstellung so gut, dass gerade jemand Kastani reingerufen hat und vorher mit seinem Kumpel gewettet hat und der sich so ein lustiges Rein-Ruf-Spiel überlegt für den heutigen Abend. Und er hat gesagt, weißt du, was du heute unterbringst für ein Wort? Kastanie. Und er hat gerade recht gehabt und hat es gut untergebracht. Klassische Podcast-Ufobingo gespielt, ah, sie wissen Wort irgendwann nicht und haben sich vorhin überlegt. Kastanie. Ja, aber es stimmt, glaube ich, wirklich. Aber auch komisch, Kastanien haben ja so eine Hülle mit Stacheln, das heisst, die wollen nicht gefressen werden, aber ist es nicht so bei Bäumen, dass die Früchte gefressen werden müssen, dass die sich weiterpflanzen können? Ich bin 28 Jahre alt und habe Sex nicht verstanden, nicht mal auf der Ebene von Bäumen, ich habe es wirklich einfach nicht verstanden. Gibt es ja auch dieses grosse Buchsbaum-Problem? Och Gott, jetzt kommt das hier. In meiner Heimatstadt ein Riesenproblem.
Es ist alles in Zeitungen und ist voll, weil es so einen Buchsbaum, so eine Raufe gibt, die die ganzen Buchsbäume auffressen. Ich weiss nicht mal genau, was Buchsbaum-Problemen, was Buchsbäume sind, dass es gerade auch so ein Problem werden kann. Aber anscheinend sind aber diese schönen, aber diese Klischeebüsche. Wenn du Busch malen würdest, würdest du glaube ich instinktiv einen Buchsbaum malen. Und die sind ein Problem. Die sind jetzt irgendwie, weil es von China aus Versehen so eine kleine Larve importiert wurde. Der Zinsling! Okay, ihr kommt auf die Bühne, wir setzen uns sehen, ihr übernehmt das ab jetzt einfach. Es funktioniert nicht. Wahnsinn. Inbrünstig. Der wurde jetzt importiert und das ist ein grosses Problem, aber anscheinend hier auch. Deutschlandweit. Der Ausländer-Hass ist einfach sehr tiefe Wurzeln hier. Da weist man sofort. Scheisschen-Netzmen. Scheiss Zinslinger. Zinslinger. Ja, Zinslinger. Einen Applaus für Ausseinerfeindlichkeit! Minger! Sehr gut. Da bitt mir richtig warmes Herz. Weiß man einfach, dass man zuhause angekommen ist in der Heimat. Zuhause ist, wenn alle ausseinerfeindlich sind. Zuhause ist, wenn man sogar Käfer hassen kann. Ein gemeinsames Feindbild. Ist das nicht die Lösung für Rassismus, einfach so ein Insekt importieren? Ja, stimmt. Und der ganze Hass konzentriert sich darauf. Wie kann ein Insekt chinesisch sein? Also wie... Nee, ist es ja nicht. Also ich meine, die kamen alle mal von irgendwo anders her und jetzt... Die haben auch so kleine Schlitzaugen. Wenn wir jetzt nicht mehr... Och, oh, Schäfer. Das ist jetzt... Wo ist hier die Grenze? Wo ist hier die Grenze? Bu-Rufe! Was? Aber auch alle, dass ihr euch alle einigen könnt, dass da die Grenze ist.
Ja, absolut. Da machen wir nicht mehr.
Absolut.
Okay, gut. Sorry, ich komme von ausserhalb. Ich kenne eure Regeln noch nicht.
Ist übrigens 1-0. Nee, ist Werbung noch. Ich sag Bescheid.
Ja. Das ist verwirrend. Aber gut, müssen wir jetzt durch. Aber was für ein paar Tage hier, du hast noch mal alle deine alten Freunde gesehen. Ja, schön, noch mal Münchener Dom angeguckt, ganze Sachen angeschaut. Ich habe mich willkürlich in Vorlesungen reingesetzt in meiner alten Universität. Das habe ich tatsächlich zu Studienzeiten auch gemacht, weil ich hatte einen sehr merkwürdigen Stundenplan. Ich hatte um acht Uhr Vorlesung und dann irgendwie nochmal um zwanzig Uhr Vorlesung. Und dann habe ich mich dazwischen einfach in random Vorlesungen reingesetzt. Das kann man einfach so machen. Ja, kann mich niemand davon abhalten. Ja, das... Du, zwischen dir... Ich glaube schon, dass man dich wohl etwas abhalten kann. Niemand kann mich von Wissen abhalten, das wisst ihr ganz genau. Wenn ich wissen will, wie italienischer Faschismus funktioniert, dann sitze ich in der Vorlesung und höre mir alles an und verstehe nichts. Und sitze in der Vorlesung und nickt an und sage Si, Si, Si, Senor, Oh, Si, Claro, und dann gehe ich wieder nach Hause. Aber es ist auch so Vorlesungen, wo der Professor manchmal, so wie man das aus Filmen kennt, aus Social Network zum Beispiel, wo er einfach auf Jesse Eisenberg zeigt und ihm eine Frage stellt. Ja, genau. Ist das auch so, dass du dann in so eine unangenehme Situation kommen kannst? Es ist ein bisschen so, und dann sagt man La Mussolini, Le Mussolini, Nusson Mussolini und dann wow, und das nach einer Stunde. Und dann sagt man, oh, ich habe was zu Hause vergessen, Zinsler zu Hause vergessen. Geschichtsunterricht ist immer so, wenn man eine Serie schaut, wo man den Anfang nicht gesehen hat. Irgendwie so, man wird immer reingeworfen und man sagt sich so, ja, da kamen die Faschisten nach Italien und die haben dann hier so Paraden gemacht und so, wow, was, wo kommt der her, was ist die Backstory, gibt es da ein Flashback, wo erfahre ich nochmal was von dem, du hast einfach keine Ahnungnung. Die Wirtschaft war schlecht, warum war die Wirtschaft schlecht? Die ist halt schlecht. Die ist halt immer schlecht. Man fängt doch schon bei den Neandertalern an, oder nicht? Ja, bei der Uni nicht mehr. Jede gute Geschichte fängt mit einer schlechten Wirtschaft an. Das ist einfach mal meine These. Einfach am Anfang war die Wirtschaft schlecht und allen ging es schlecht, aber dann und alle so, ja, ja, Krieg. Das ist einfach so, ja Das ist meistens schlechte Wirtschaft, Krieg, Besserung, doch nicht Besserung, doch Besserung. Schöne Uniform, schöne Uniform, langweilige Uniform. Hat man jemand so einen Graph gemacht, der lauft der Menschheitsgeschichte an Uniformen, Schönheit? Ja, ich glaube, je böser die Diktatur, desto schöner die Uniform. Ja, ist eine gute These, kannst du dir mal vorbringen eigentlich beim nächsten Mal. Einfach so der Stefan-Tietze-Index. Bei wem bringt man solche Thesen vor? Hugo Boss. Ich glaube, die sagen ja. Einfach mal sagen, ja. Ich glaube, die sehen das ähnlich. Ist das nicht so, dass italienische Polizisten Handschuhe tragen? Fun fact. Handschuhe tragen? Einfach mal rausge... rausge... Ich habe mal jemand mit einem freund von mir unterhalten er meinte so also ich muss es echt mal sagen ich finde die uniformen von italienischen polizisten ist echt schön das ist auch so ein Gesprächsthema wo du wirklich sofort so dein Gehirn fließt so in einem Fluss weg einfach so und du stehst so und ja keiner hat keinen Plan hat. Aber das sind eigentlich so Sätze, wenn so ein Freundeskreis beisammen ist und alle haben eine gute Zeit und der Gesprächsfluss fließt und dann kommt Monsieur, der dänische Polizisten tragen Handschuhe. Ja, ja. Oder findet ihr nicht, sind die nicht auch schön? Also kommt so ein Kran und nimmst du das Gehirn aus meinem Kopf und wer findet zuerst die Ausrede, ich geh kurz noch mal Getränke holen?
Sieben Leute gleichzeitig, oh ich geh kurz auf den Flo einfach. Es funktioniert nicht. Aber ich weiss nicht, ob das stimmt, ob die Handschuhe tragen oder nicht.
Ich weiss es nicht. Wen könnten wir fragen. Keiner wegen dem Pizzateig vielleicht irgendwie, ich weiss es nicht genau. Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Das ist mir okay oder was? Was sie so fangen müssen. Ich verstehe es nicht.
Die Italiener mit ihren Pizzen ist okay. Ja, die haben noch Schmerzaugen! Oh, buh Stefan! Wehe, du sagst Stäbchen. Wenn du Stäbchen sagst, schmeiße die raus. Gott sei Dank, fängt das Spiel jetzt an. Alles klar, wir sind uns in 90 Minuten. Das wär so... Wir würden so werden die, genau wir würden so einen Public Viewing Abend moderieren, das wäre wirklich die massivste Fehlbesetzung aller Zeiten, glaube ich. Das ist das Schlimmste, wir mussten mal, damals einer der grössten Bandauftritte war nach einem Deutschlandspiel auf einem Friedensplatz in Dortmund, das ist ein riesiger Platz, und wir haben das irgendwie gewonnen und wir dachten, das ist ja unglaublich, das ist ein Durchbruch, da passen 20.000 Leute drauf.
Es ist kein, fun fact, kein Durchbruch, wenn Deutschland verliert und man danach auf einem Friedensplatz vor zwei Leuten spielen muss und der Platz ist unfassbar leer und einer von diesen zwei Leuten ist ein Deutschlehrer, der angetrunken ist und dir so einen Döner auf die Bühne schmeißt. Das war eine ganz weirde Situation. But he did it. Ja, es ist schwer, es ist schwer. Wohingegen, wenn die Handballmannschaft verliert? Es ist halt nur Handball. Dürfen die Ball in die Hand nehmen. Ball am Fuss, ja, Ball in der Hand. Schon wieder so eine willkürliche Grenze. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee,ängt man ja an so und dann bist du halt so wirklich, dann machst du die, irgendwie bist du vier Jahre alt und dann machst du mit den Behinderten zusammen Training und so und ist alles scheißegal. Und dann geht es immer höher und dann bist du bei den, einfach nur mal den Vibe aus Hessen und dann bist du irgendwann bei den Minis und dann geht es von den Minis in die E-Jugend. Und da hat man schon gemerkt, zu Minis ist noch hier so Spass, irgendwie ha ha ha, oh, hört auf Sinn zu treten, wenn er am Boden liegt.
E-Jugend war dann da hat man schon gemerkt, zu Minis ist noch hier so Spaß, irgendwie ha ha ha, oh, hört auf den zu treten, wenn er am Boden liegt. E-Jugend war dann so, du spielst rechts außen, du bist Mit-Innenverteidiger. Und ich habe nie den Sprung geschafft, von Minis zu E-Jugend. Und in der E-Jugend haben die auch angefangen mit dem Harz. Ja, und so eine Taktiktafel reinzuschieben. Taktiktafel, wirklich alles. Wo kommt die hin? Du faulst den, du faulst den und alles so. Und das war... Und dann als die diesen Bottich-Harz reingefahren haben, dachte ich mir schon, das ist nicht mein Sport. Ich mag keinen Sport, wo man klebrige Hände hat. Sorry, ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel verlangen. Aber es funktioniert einfach. Braucht man das wirklich? Oder es ist nicht so, ey wir haben ganz viel Harz. Jeder Baum wirkt Harz ab. Entweder wir kriegen von China irgendwie so einen Zinsler reingeballert, der uns den Harz hier weckt. Und wir haben einfach zu viel Harz. Welche Sportart, welche sind so dusselig, die man einfach so Harz unterjubeln kann? Ich hatte das erste Mal einen Handball in der Hand und hab gesagt, Freunde, pass auf, der ist zu gross. Den kann ich nicht in die Hand halten, der ist zu gross. Und alle so, ach, jetzt stell dich nicht so an, irgendwie Stokastik kriegst du da hin, so, der ist ist nicht zu gross aber dann kommen sie und haben harz an der hand weil der ball zu gross ist weil ich den sonst nicht halten kann wo ich sag nee tut das scheiß harz weg mach den ball kleiner so golfball so das krieg ich hin ja das können wir machen aber nicht zu sagen ja wir machen den ball groß je grösser der ball desto mehr harz braucht man ja es ist funktioniert einfach nichtste Sportart. Sorry an alle Handballfans. Bei Baseball verstehe ich es aber auch nicht, dass man diesen Handschuh hat. Ist es nicht unterhaltsamer, wenn der Ball schwieriger zu fangen wäre? Warum brauchst du diesen Handschuh, der es leichter macht? Ja, das ist ein guter Punkt. Vielleicht hatten die Menschen früher grosse Hände und dann kannst du einfach sagen, damit es fair bleibt, brauchst du einen grossen Handschuh oder so. Ich weiss es nicht. Und die Statistik gleich. Keine Ahnung. Ich weiss ja auch nicht, warum die immer diese Orgelmusik bei Baseball haben. Und Eishockey. Ist das dann wirklich ein Organist? Kein Orgel, komm jetzt nicht mit deinen Klassikfragen wieder. Dann melden sich die ganzen, nicht so ein Klassikmusiker, aber wir haben viele Einsendungen bekommen von vielen verschiedenen Musikern, die uns alle sehr gut gefallen haben. Aber tatsächlich einfach bei zwei Sportarten eine Orgel.
Einfach so Orgel, Kirche und Baseballplatz.
Einfach so, das sind die beiden einzigen und Jazz vielleicht, wie so Helge Schneider Jazz ein bisschen.
Aber ansonsten hat die Orgel einfach keine Bewandtnis.
Hat mich auch geärgert, Free Solo, dieser Film über den Kletterer, der hatte auch so weisses Zeug dabei.
Achso, ich dachte, Orgel.
So eine kleine, ich kletter nicht ohne meine Orgel. Komm schon, überleg dir das noch mal. Und Orgel. Und er hatte auch immer so weisses Pulver dabei, damit die Hände nicht trocken werden, wo ich mir auch dachte, ja, wenn du feuchte Hände hast, dann sollst du nicht klettern, mein Junge. Habe ich bei IMDB in die Kommentare geschrieben. Feuchte Hände, nix klettert mein Lieber. Gell? Fucking fun. Darf ich einen Vorschlag für das unsympathischste Wort der Welt machen? Gell. Gell. Es ist wirklich gell. Das ist also die falsche Stadtausgesucht für diese These. Nee, nee, nee, es ist wirklich gell. Das ist so dieses Überhebliche, wenn man irgendwie, man postet einen rassistischen Witz und dann sagen irgendwie so, wir wollen mal nicht rassistisch sein, gell?
Ich finde diese Wir-Form auch schon wahnsinnig unsympathisch.
Ja, on y va. In Frankreich ist ja oft dieses Wir, dieses Man.
Damit wollen wir es gar nicht anfangen, oder?
Ekelhaft, ja, genau.
Das ist unangenehm, passiv-aggressiv.
Schrecklich, zum Glück machen das Podcast-Uvo-Hörer nicht. Das ist doch wichtig. Das würde niemals passieren. Ha! Gut. Hallo Mama. Okay. Gut dafür. Weißt du, was eine unglaublich unangenehme Situation ist, habe ich gemerkt. Ich habe ja immer das Bedürfnis, als möglichst stark darzustehen. Stark selbstbewusst nimmt die Probleme in die Hand. Ich glaube, so seht ihr mich auch. Merkt man gar nicht. Ich glaube, die meisten würden mich schon so beschreiben. Wenn angenommen, ich würde verloren gehen, würden, glaube ich, die Podcast-UFO-Hörer so Zettel aufhängen. Stark, selbstbewusst, gut aussehen. Ne, ich würde den Zettel aufhängen, würde keine zwei Tage alleine überleben. Ja, ja, ja, okay. Gut. Und tatsächlich, du willst ja am Alltag immer so männlich, selbstbewusst dastehen. Und eine Situation, in der es mir sehr selten funktioniert, ist am Snackautomaten. Und die schlimmste Situation am Snackautomaten ist mir letztens passiert in der Hotellobby. Ist mir passiert, Snackautomat, jemand steht hinter einem, erstmal schon mal wahnsinnig unangenehm, die Wahl ist eh nicht leicht, was mit Mauerfuck, Mr. Tom, Bounty, so man weiss nicht genau, was man nehmen soll und dann, man wirft einen, der hinter dir guckt genau, wer er auch sucht, man wirft einen, drückt auf den Knopf, es dreht sich und fällt nicht rund. Bleibt stehen. Und dann stehst du da und denkst, ich kann jetzt nicht einfach gehen, ich kann jetzt nicht einfach mein gesamtes Geld eingeworfen haben, kriegt nichts und dann, hm, geht man. Der Mann hinter dir freut sich schon so, weil wenn er Glück hat, nimmt er das über dem Mr. Tom und es fällt runter, es fällt rum und nimmt den Mr. Tom noch mit. Richtig. Und er aber denkt sich auch so, was macht er jetzt?
Lässt er sich das gefallen von einem Automaten?
Gewinnt der Automaten jetzt gegen diesen starken Mann?
Oh, der Automat hat mein Geld, oh, was macht er jetzt?
Und dann hast du den Automaten beschlagen.
Das ist nämlich der Trick.
Nee, ich bin einfach kurz registriert, kurz nochmal in die Klappe geguckt, leer, ja, dann halt nicht. Ja! Ich bin nach Hause gegangen. Man kann nicht viel machen, man würde so gern einfach sagen, so, was ist denn hier los, so geht's nicht, aber nee, du musst einfach diese Niederlage annehmen. Und es tut mir einfach im Herzen weh, weil du drehst dich einfach um undst dir, ich lasse mich von einer Maschine rumschubsen. Ich habe weniger Selbstbewusstsein als eine Maschine. Mir ist was ähnliches passiert, war in einem Backwerk und das muss man sagen, dieser eine Backwerk, wo ich an dem ich morgens vorbeikomme, da sollte man vielleicht auch nicht einkaufen gehen, ist glaube ich moralisch auf sehr vielen Ebenen falsch, aber es ist der einzige Bäcker, an dem ich morgens vorbeikomme und der ist so komisch gebaut, dass man sich ganz weird nur anstellen kann.
Und beim Anstehen schon sämtlichen anderen Leuten den Zugang zu ihren Brötchenfächern versperrt. Das ist wirklich Krieg, dieser Backwerk ist Krieg. Und das Problem ist, wenn es zu voll ist, versperren alle alles und man steht da ewig an. Und dann habe ich aber schon gesehen, ah, okay, die Stange ist so voll und sie hat schon diesen Buzzer ausgelöst, der dem anderen Backwerk Mitarbeiter, Backwerker sagt, sich jetzt an die andere Klasse stellen zu können. Das habe ich registriert. Niemand der anderen, und man muss sagen, Deutsche sind echt schlecht im Anstellen, komme ich gleich noch dazu, um diese These zu unterfüttern. Okay. Und dann habe ich das gesehen, ich habe gesehen, niemand von denen registriert gerade, dass der jetzt kommt.
Und ich habe mich quasi, dann kam er dahin und ich habe mich sofort davor gedrängelt. Ich war der ganz Letzte aus der Schlange, wirklich, ich hätte bestimmt 20 Minuten gewarten müssen und bin halt gecuttet und bin direkt zur neuen Kasse gegangen und habe meinen Kaffee dahingestellt. Und man muss sagen, niemand hat es mir übel genommen wirklich. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Das kann ich mir beim besten wehen. Nein, die haben alle eingesehen, jeder war einfach schneller.
Ja klar, natürlich die sagen, der ist schneller als ich, deswegen muss er nicht warten.
Vielleicht waren sie wahnsinnig angepisst.
Ich glaube, sie waren wahnsinnig angepisst.
Kann auch gut sein.
Jedenfalls ist man, und ich war so stolz, ich weiß nicht, ob sie sehr stolz war, aber ich habe dann den Becher genommen und da muss man den offen machen, damit die noch sehen, wie viel man genommen hat, damit man bezahlen kann. Dann geht man da hin und zu der Station und dann macht man den Deckel drauf. Und ich weiß nicht, ich habe mich die ganze Zeit gefreut, dass ich so schnell diese Line geskippt habe und habe dann, ich weiß nicht, was in mich gefahren ist, den Deckel zu sehr draufgedrückt oder sowas und da war dann das Tablett noch drauf. Jedenfalls habe ich das Tablett nicht richtig hingestellt, der Kaffee ist, habe ich drunter gedrückt und es stand nicht richtig, das Tablett ist umgekippt und der ganze Kaffee ist auf dem Boden und der ganze Backwerk, das war so ein grosser 0-4, 0-5 Becher Kaffee auf dem Boden und dann haben die so einen Alarm ausgelöst, was ich nicht kannte, ich wusste nicht, dass es das gibt, aber dann gibt es neben dem, die neue Kasse muss aufgemacht werden, gibt's einen Kaffee-Alarm und dann wussten alle sofort, was passiert und niemand hat mich böse angeguckt von den Mitarbeitern, die ganzen Leute waren wahnsinnig angepisst, weil jetzt alles noch länger dauert, aber dann haben die so einen Alarm ausgelöst und dann kamen so zwei Frauen mit so einem Lappen, tatsächlich einfach so, als ob die ganze Zeit darauf warten, auf jeden Einsatz. So Balljungen, so von links und von rechts. Ja, wie so eine Boxen-Stop-Crew. Ja, tatsächlich hat jedes Backwerk dann so einen Knopf mit deinem Gesicht drauf und einfach so, Stefan-Tietze-Alarm. Ja, und dann zack. Und dann habe ich auch mich überlegt, es ist halt wahnsinnig voll in dem Laden, was mache ich jetzt? Und dann habe ich gesehen, die kümmern sich, die meinten, die haben, brauchen sie dich nicht so kümmern, wir machen das schon jetzt sauber und dann bin ich einfach gekangen. Und dann gehst du halt, du warst gefühlt eine Viertelstunde in diesem Backwerk, um deinen Kaffee zu kaufen und gehst ohne Kaffee wieder raus und hinter dir hast du so ein Schlachtfeld hinterlassen. Und das war wirklich unangenehm. Und das ist genauso wie mit dem Automaten. Mich hat niemand übers Ohr gezogen, es war einfach ich selber. Da war ich wahrscheinlich so, guck mal Rita, der wollte gar keinen Kaffee.ee. Nee. Der wollte keinen Durst. Ja, du wolltest nichts. Aber so verschenkte Lebenszeit. Straight in Starbucks dann einfach von der Seite. Und dann fünf Minuten später wetzt du wieder aus dem Starbucks und aus ohne Kaffee. Und so eine Rauchwolke, ich steige aus dem Starbucks so. Komplett der Bahnhof ist lahmgelegt. Ach ja, das ist wirklich uneingelegend. Zum Glück krieg ich nur Getränke, die völlig unbedenklich sind. Einfach, ich hol mir eine schöne Mate aus dem Kühlschrank, zahle die, fertig. Ich hab dieses ganze Kaffeezeug. Ja, ja. Da ist noch Scherben. Ja, das stimmt. Ja, das stimmt. Das stimmt. Ich finde das wirklich ein Problem. Als ich in Chicago war bei der Star Wars Celebration, habe ich mal wieder gesehen, wie gut sich Leute anstellen können im Ausland. Tatsächlich, da gibt es dann diese Panels und dann steht man da ewig lange voran, wenn man schon früh da war, dann viele gute Plätze haben will. Und dann gibt es da zum einen diese Labyrinthe, die man kennt, und dann gibt es, wenn das vorbei ist, bilden die aber sich eine Zweierschlange quasi bis zum Ende Ende. Und in Deutschland wäre einfach so ein Knubbelmenschen. Deutschland am Skilift Knubbel. Einfach einen Haufen Menschen und alle regen sich auf, alle sind wahnsinnig angepisst. Und es ist so ein kontinuierliches Drängeln und Schubsen, so ein Moshpit. Aber in den USA sind einfach ein Zweierreihe Menschen und die haben sich dann hingesetzt auch, so geordnet. Und diese Schlange ging ging ewig durch das ganze Convention Center, war diese Schlange. Und ich habe nicht gecheckt, weil die sich so fein säuberlich sortiert haben, war die halt ewig lang. Es war einfach kein Knubbel. Und ich Deutscher bin einfach an denen vorbei, weil ich dachte, was machen die da? Kaffee links, Kaffee rechts, aber fuck all. Warum sitzen die da so und bin einfach vor allem vorbeigegangen in den Panel hinein und die ganzen Leute saßen da auf dem Boden und dachten, what the fuck is he doing? Die waren einfach sauer, weil ich da vorbei wusste nicht, was ich mache und dachte mir, man ruten mich alle so böse an und bin so nichts an, einfach an den vorbei und war der Erste. Aber auch weil ich nicht gecheckt habe, was die da alle machen, warum sitzen die an der Wand. Klar, in Deutschland ist es eher darwinistisch, der Ansteller, der am meisten dafür tut, gewinnt. Ja, der am gehetztesten aussieht. In den USA ist der, der als erstes da ist, kommt der als erstes rein, der als erstes da, der kommt der als letztes rein. In Deutschland ist es so ein bisschen so, wer die Line cuttet. Ja, der die angestrengteste Körperhaltung hat. Der dreisteste Mensch gewinnt. Auch ein deutsches Ding ist, wenn Kassen, eine neue Kasse aufgemacht wird, wie ich gerade gesagt habe, dass alle direkt das Bedürfnis haben, dahin zu rennen, statt dem, der vorne steht, zu erlauben, die neue Kasse zu benutzen. Nee, auf keinen Fall. In Deutschland alle direkt die Augen werden zu schlitzen, erst mal direkt dahin. Ja, ja, aber ich spüre tatsächlich ein tief deutsches Gen in mir, wenn es ums Anstellen geht. Was ich nicht leiden kann, ist, ich bin ja sehr oft an Bahnhöfen und da hast du dann so einen Bäcker am Bahnhof und dann ist immer die Frage, in welche Richtung schlängelt sich die Schlange. Und oft schlängelt sich die Schlange in den Weg des Bahnhofs rein, sodass diese Schlange alle aufhält. Und ich nehme es mir selber zum Anlass, diese Schlange wieder auf den rechten Weg zu bringen
und stelle mich dann so seitlich an, so im 90-Grad-Winkel, für die bayerischen Abiturienten so, stelle ich mich so seitlich an,
damit die Schlange langfristig wieder rumläuft und dann hast du dieses klassische Y-Problem, dass irgendjemand kommt und sich wieder in die Richtung der ursprünglichen Schlange anschaut. Sagst du dann was? Ich sage viel, aber nicht mit Worten. Ja, wirklich, dann kommt der Blick und das enttäuschte Schnaufen. Und er so, höh? Und dann will ich so der Blick in die Gasse rein, also in die Hauptstrasse des Bahnhofs, so, aber wirklich nichts, einfach leere Augen, leere Augen und dann stehst du und dann hast du halt so diese Y-Schlange und machst alles nur noch schlimmer. Wie sieht ein Y aus für dich? So,, und dann hast du erst die Schlange, du hast erst die Schlange und ich mach dann sozusagen die Ausfahrt auf und dann stellen sich manche hinter mir an und manche hinter der anderen und dann hast du eine absolute Katastrophe und dann hast du acht Leuten, die enttäuscht, schnaufend die andere Seite angreifen und ich glaube, so fangen Weltkriege an, einfach so, dass du einfach sagst, wer ist auf meiner Seite, wer ist auf deren Seite. Es funktioniert nicht in Deutschland, das anstellt. Ich würde wirklich, es gibt ja, man hört ja manchmal, dass Leute ehrenamtlich sich engagieren und man denkt sich, ja, sollen sie machen. Warum erzählt er mir das? Aber gut, soll ich das auch machen?
Ja, soll ich das auch machen? Warum macht er das und ich nicht, warum macht sie das und ich nicht?
Und denkst du dir, muss ich denn irgendwo mitmachen ehrenamtlich oder kann ich mir selber meine ehrenamtliche Tätigkeit aussuchen?
Und ich hätte nämlich den Vorschlag für eine ehrenamtliche Tätigkeit, nämlich den Bahnhofsnazi, der einfach schön mit so einer Kappe zum Schlagstock durch den Bahnhof läuft und einfach sagt,
Vielen Dank. Nämlich den Bahnhofsnazi, der einfach schön mit so einer Kappe zum Schlagstock durch den Bahnhof läuft und einfach sagt, pass auf, du Volldepp stehst hier falsch, warum stehst du denn direkt vor der Rolltreppe, stell dich gerade hin. Der zur Bäckerei geht und sagt, so einmal schön die Reihe einfach. Und zwar auch in den USA besser gelöst, wenn du da bei den Sicherheitschecks ankommst, hast du einfach einen Sicherheitscheckzi. Du hast einfach jemanden, der mitdenkt. Finde ich Schuhe aus! Ja. Einfach, und das ist nur Bullshit. Man macht alles richtig bis zum Zeitpunkt. Wenn du einen Fehler begehst, wirst du kaputt gemacht. Glaub mir, jeder Bahnhof nach einem Monat und meinem Engagement ist nicht mehr wiederzuerkennen. Ist nicht mehr wiederzuerkennen. Ein Haufen bekränkter, schwitzender, nervöser Menschen. Sobald Leute mal darauf angesprochen werden, dass sie falsch stehen, wird es auch mehr und mehr in ihr Bewusstsein einfließen. Und dann denken sie nach, wo stehe ich denn, wem stehe ich denn im Weg. Wirklich, ich habe mir sogar, ich habe mir schon Uniform überlegt, ich habe dann so eine, ich habe so eine SS-Kappe und da oben drauf ist dann so eine wie so eine einem kleinen Zug und der baumelt dann so rum, dass Leute schon von ganz weit mich so ... Angst bekommen. Und dann sehen sie das ... Das ist Quiz auch, eine Quitschen zu hören, wie ein Horrorfilm, wo so ein Geräusch schon immer ... Alle zucken schon so zusammen. Und alle so, oh Gott, oh Gott, stehe ich richtig, stehe ich richtig? In der Ferne sieht man schon so Schlangen sich neu formatieren. Ja. Ja. Und dann habe ich dann auch so einen kleinen Raum, wo die reinkommen, die nicht gehorchen, das Kontrollzentrum, kommen die rein. Was passiert die ganze, zurück zu diesem Raum. Hä? Dieser Raum, wo Leute reinkommen, die nicht gehorchen. Ja, die sind ja nicht lang da drin. Die nicht deiner Ideologie entsprechen. Nein, die sind nicht lang da drin. Was, nee, das macht mir noch mehr Angst. Gut. Warum sind die nicht so lang da drin? Was passiert denn mit denen? Nun, die sollen ja ihre Lektion lernen, damit irgendwann der Bahnhof wieder besser funktioniert. Herr Wild, das ist genau meine Angst. Wie wollen Sie denn die Lektion erteilen? Naja, Arbeit, Macht.
Alles klar. Nein, aber es ist ja, man muss ja jetzt nicht so weit gehen. Aber ich glaube, es würde allen deutschen Bahnhöfen gut tun, wenn einfach mal jemand da die Kontrolle übernimmt und einfach mal sagt, hier ist kein rechtsfreier Raum mehr. Man kann nicht mehr tun, was man will, einfach, sondern macht das. Hier ist kein rechtsfreier Raum mehr, nee, hier ist ein rechter Raum. Aber darf man das, darf man sich selber sein, darf ich das ehrenamtlich nennen oder darf man nur sagen, ich mache ehrenamtlich was, wenn man irgendwo mitmacht? Das darfst du amtlich nennen. Okay, amtlich. Wenn nicht wie viel Ehre da mitschwingt. Unehrenamtliches Engagement nebenbei. Engagement. Ich mach das, wirklich. Aber es ist kein Bahnhofsproblem, es ist ein allgemeines Problem. Es herrscht zu wenig. Okay, vielleicht müssen wir unsere Grenzen erweitern. Guter Punkt. Guter, gut. Im ganzen Land ein Problem. Sehr gut, sehr gut. Gefällt mir, was du sagst. Nein, ich glaube, das Problem ist einfach, dass die Leute, die Leute sehen sich immer nur von innen. Ich glaube, Menschen, die Videospiele spielen, sind bessere Menschen, weil sie es gewohnt sind, von außen auf ihre Spielfigur zu gucken und immer sich denken, nimm die Flasche, nimm die Goldmünze, laufe nicht ins Lava, so. Und dann haben die immer so eine Aussensicht, was mache ich, wo bin ich gut, wo bin ich schlecht. Und das überträgt man auch und überlegt sich im alltäglichen Leben. Man hat es gelernt, sich selber durch so eine Vogelperspektive zu erfahren. Und rennen. Man rennt viel. Und rennen und man macht immer diese Rolle, um schneller zu sein. Und so runde Lichter auf dem Boden ziehen dann magisch an, aber man denkt, da ist irgendwie so ein Coupon. Und dann zwei Abenteurer kommen sich entgegen und rollen so. Roll, roll, morgen, roll, roll. Und bevor man antwortet, erwartet man unten auch auf die Auswahlmöglichkeiten, wie man sagen kann. Ja, und ich glaube, deswegen haben alte Menschen Probleme, sich in der Umwelt zurechtzufinden, weil sie diese Vogelperspektive nicht erhält. Ja, das ist das Problem. Nicht weil Gehör langsam zurückgeht. Weißt du, was es gibt? Es gibt ja so Go-Kart-Bahnen, wo man eine VR-Brille trägt. Wo man sich von oben sieht? Und dann sieht man sich selber wie Mario Kart! What? Also da ist dann anscheinend am Go-Kart so ein langer Stock, wo so eine Kamera runterfilmt. So, und dann sehen die sich selber. Wirklich, jetzt mal ganz im Ernst, und ich mein's hundertprozentig ernst, wenn du so durch die Welt läufst, wie Arbrille an und du siehst dich selber von oben, nie wieder würdest du im Weg stehen, weil du einfach verstehst, wo die Umgebung ist, wo, ah, wo stehe ich, wo ist der, ah, jetzt kommt er hinter mir, ah, der guckt blöse, so, und dann geht das alles weiter. Du rennst so wahnsinnig auf die Wände, weil du nicht, du siehst Türen nicht, ist ein grosses Problem, es ist ein Abgetaste von Wänden. Es kann sein. Wobei, man könnte auch mit Schildern auf dem Boden dagegen wirken, mit grossen Schildern Tür und so. Wir finden Wege, wir finden Wege. Aber wirklich, na jetzt denken wir doch einfach mal in die Zukunft. Wir sind ja ein zukunftsbildender Podcast. In der Zukunft, glaube ich, wird jeder sich so bewegen und dann kann dann irgendwie der Bahnhofsmeister kann dann so Power-Ups dahin legen, wo er will, dass die Leute laufen. Und dann kann man auch so Leute sich auseinander und dann kriegst du Punktabzug, wenn du jemandem im Weg stehst und so kannst du alles durchregeln. Und man wird auch sehr viel schneller, wenn man auf dem gleichen Weg bleibt. Auf dem richtigen Weg. So Power-Boost-Felder. Ja, so Boost. Schwer umzusetzen, aber... Und Items. Ja. Schau mal vor, du hättest den Typen, der hinter dir den Mr. Tom will. So schön so ein Schildkrötenpanzer gegen das Gesicht. Ja, stimmt schon. Dann kriegt der Punktabzug. Das ist eigentlich ein guter Punkt. Ja. Ich glaube, es funktioniert so. Es gibt jetzt, ich weiss nicht, ist ja auch egal, ob Leute das Spiel Dota 2 kennen, aber da gab es jetzt ein neues Update sozusagen. Und da kann man Spieler festlegen, mit denen man nie wieder spielen will. Du spielst mit Spielern und sagst, weißt du, pass auf, du bist ein Depp. Und dann hast du diesen Depp-Button und dann klickst du da drauf. Ist das wie so ein halbes Blockieren? Das heißt, du kannst noch gegen den spielen, aber nicht mehr mit dem spielen? Nee, ich glaube, du siehst den nie wieder. Und das müsste auch für das echte Leben liegen. Aber das ist ein Problem irgendwann. Ja, das weiß ich nicht. Angenommen, du heiratest und da musst du so Hochzeitstische bilden, aber die einen können nicht mit dem und die anderen können nicht mit dem. Das stimmt. So stelle ich mir das dann auch vor, dass das Programm irgendwann sagt, so Leute, wir kriegen kein Fünferteam mehr zusammen. Ja, also ich glaube, solange es genug Spieler gibt, kann es funktionieren, aber das war so ein Ding, wo ich es meinte, das ist zukunftsträchtig. Du kannst dann irgendwann Leute festlegen, von denen du einfach nie wieder was siehst, so eine Ignorierenliste, einfach.
Was auch so spricht, dass man irgendwann mit einer VR-Brille rumläuft,
man kann einfach Leute ausblenden.
Geht das?
Ja.
Aber was ist denn hinter den Leuten?
Werbung. So was sieht man dann statt der...
Coca-Cola-Werbung.
Werbung.
Ja.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Menschen als Werbefläche.
Ja.
Wieso wandelnde Litfaussäulen.
Man erkennt aber noch an den Umrissen der Werbung, wer es ist. Man ist so ein bisschen genervt. Oh, Rita. Das ist eine gute Idee, aber irgendwann machst du bis dann deine Hochzeit und schaust du in die Runde und alles Werbung einfach. Die gesamten Familien einfach alles Werbung. Und guckst du zu deinem Partner, auch Werbung. Oh, Krombacher lecker, oder? Ja, ne, eine Tante, Tante Rita. Hast du eine gute Beziehung zu deiner Tante? Ich habe mehrere Tanten, gute Beziehungen zu Tanten, ja. Ich mag das Wort Tante einfach, das ist einfach dieser Worte, die einfach gut klingen. Onkel. Ja, Onkel, ne, Tante, Onkel. Das ist eine Tante, so, Tante, das hat einfach was. Das klingt ein bisschen wie ein Schimpfwort. Ja, Tante, wie Ente, Tante? Alte Tante, du. Tante da. Aber Onkel ist so sympathisierend. Onkel. Onkel, Wonkel, Tante. Das ist aggressiv, spitz. Irgendwann, ich glaube, irgendwann kommt der Moment, wo ich mich mit meiner Tante nochmal versöhne. Du hast Stress mit deiner Tante. Ich habe keinen Stress mit meiner Tante, es ist einfach so, man lebt halt so ein Tante-Neffe-Leben. Uiuiuiui. Ja, Neffe. Uiuiuiui. Leben und ich weiß es nicht, vielleicht kommt noch der Moment, wo man mal sagt, es gibt immer so Filme, wo dann irgendwie die Familie zusammenkommt und dann lernt man sich nochmal neu kennen und so. Und ich denke, mir passiert sowas in der echten Welt auch? Ja, doch, glaube ich, nach dem Tod. Nach dem Tod? Ja, nach dem Tod eines Familienmitglieds. Da rutschen alle zusammen. Ah, und dann sagt man, jetzt sind es weniger, jetzt muss ich mir weniger Namen merken, jetzt krieg ich es auch einigermaßen hin. Es stimmt schon, es stimmt schon. Weniger Geschenke. Ich habe mal gehört, es gibt irgendeine Kultur, in der, die haben nicht so viele Worte, faul, und die haben dann zum Beispiel, also du hast ja dann so Grossmutter, Mutter, Kind. So weit alle dabei? Ja, wir können eine Folge. Okay, und also jetzt sage ich mal alle weiblich. Und die haben nur zwei Wörter und die wechseln sich immer ab. Also du hast Oma, Mama, Oma, Mama, Oma. Die wechseln sich immer nur ab. Wer ist jetzt gestorben? Alle! Hä? Du hast die Enkelin und die Oma, das ist wirklich wahr, das ist irgendwie so ein ganz verreckter Stamm. Wie furchtbar, angenommen, du bist Kind in diesem Ding und dann sagt dir jemand, Oma ist gestorben. Bin ich jetzt tot? Es ist die alte Oma, die, wo ich vor ein paar Wochen noch war, wo man sagt, ja, oder es ist mein Kind. Ja, es ist schwierig. Es ist doch keine gute Idee.
Nee, es ist offensichtlich keine gute Idee, aber wir hatten keine bessere Idee. Wir haben gesagt, zwei Wörter reichen, oder? Und dann so. Ich glaube, die Eskimo-Angelegenheit, Inuit, doch. Du kriegst heute noch viele neue Follower, glaube ich. Und die haben ja auch diese ganz vielen Wörter für Schnee, 50 Wörter für Schnee, wo man auch sagt, ist das denn nötig? Also klar, klar lebt ihr da, aber warum 50 Wörter für Schnee?
Ich verstehe es auch nicht, aber sind es dann 50 verschiedene Zustände oder so?
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Weil wir sagen ja auch, Puderschnee und ...
Babschnee, sagt man in Bayern, klebender Schnee, Babschnee, Babschnee, Babschnee, Pappschnee, Pappen, ja, Bappen, ja, oft unterscheidet sich das Bayernee, Pappschnee, Pappen, Pappen, Pappschnee, Pappen, Pappen, Pappschnee, Puderschnee, Puderschnee, Buderschnee, dann geht's dann Puderschnee und Pappschnee, also hat man da auch schon zwei Worte eigentlich. Ja, genau. Oder muss er das halt noch so ein bisschen multiplizieren? Eis. Eis, ja, gut.
Ähm, Smoothie?
Hagel?
Slushy?
Gibt's Slushy?
Was würde ein Inuit zu dem Slushy sagen? Wow, ich wohne da drin und es schmeckt nach Erdbeeren. Wow, reden alle wie Bill Burr. Wow, wow, wow. Das stimmt Ja. Ob die verletzt sind,
wenn du so ein,
das war mein Freund, trinkst du es?
Ja, das ist so eine
so eine, sagen, Langnese-Kühltruhe.
Ist traumatisch, glaube ich, wir sind Inuit.
Bum bum! Was ist das?
Was machst du da drin?
Komm raus da, bum bum!
Ah, bum bum habe ich nie gemocht, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Hey! Muss ich mal sagen, nee. Was ist da drin innen? Auch Vanille? Zwei Arten Menschen. Leute, die Bum-Bum mögen, die die Bum-Bum hassen. Ja. Ist das denn mit den Kaugummis? Ja, keine Ahnung, ich weiss es nicht genau. Da war ich kein Fan von, weil ich hatte, das sind zwei Dinge, die man nicht zusammenbringen sollte. Eis und Kaugummi. Ich habe immer das billigste Eis gekauft, einfach so. Wirklich? Ja, ich hatte als Kind eine ganz einfache... Was war das billigste Eis? Immer so diese 20-Pfennigen-Milch-Eis-Milchkuh-Dinger da. Minimilk, ja genau. Und es war einfach immer so, ich hatte als Kind schon von Anfang an... Zinsler! Nein, fünf Minuten zu spät. Ich hatte schon von Anfang an als Kind immer die Devise, mehr ist besser als wenig, egal worum es geht.
Und ich habe mir immer, immer wenn ich mir gefragt habe, welches Eis willst du, ich will, pass auf Vater, das Maximalbudget, das du für ein Eis ausgeben würdest, so nimm das und geb es vollständig für Minimilk auf. Also komm mir nicht mit, mein Bruder kriegt Magnum, ich krieg Mini-Milk. So viel wie das Magnum kostet, so viel will ich in Mini-Milk. Da hast du halt so eine drei, vier Mini-Milk. Gut. Und ich dachte mir, ihr Idioten, ich hab vier Eis. Du hast fünf Mini-Milk. Ein Eis. Wir hätten gern fünf Mini-Milk Magnum. Deswegen mein Lieblingsburger bei McDonalds immer der Big Mac, weil den kann man zu zwei Burgern machen. Kann man die Hälfte abnehmen, dann hast du zwei Burger. Das ist trotzdem noch genauso viel. Ja, es geht um die Anzahl. Wenn jemand sagt, willst du mittelmässig, willst du viel schlechtes Essen oder wenig gutes Essen? Ich sag viel schlechtes Essen, sorry, so bin ich einfach veranlacht. Aber wie machst du zwei Burger draus?
Du hast doch trotzdem nur drei Brotscheiben.
Ja, dann hast du, da ist ein bisschen Ungleichgewicht tatsächlich, aber du fragst dich, stopp, ne, weiss nicht, was ist dazu lang?
Nee, ist ein Ungleichgewicht.
Stopp, erst denkst du dir, ah, pass auf, Big Mac teilen, ich habe einen richtigen Burger und so einen Anhängsel, weil einer hat zwei Brötchen, einer eins. Während du ihn aber verspeist, merkst du, Brötchen zu haben ist nicht unbedingt ein Vorteil. Tatsächlich schmeckt die Seite ohne Brötchen besser. Und dann gucke ich mal dein Gesicht sehen, weil dann hast du nämlich so dieses in einer Hand Fleisch, schön die Handfläche aufs Fleisch gedrückt, unten mit den Mayonnaisefingern schön so ein Loch reingestanzt in das Brötchen und dann klappt es auseinander und dann so aus dem Ärmel und das sind die schönsten Momente meiner Kindheit einfach, also einfach beim McDrive einfach die Hälfte auf der Rückbank.
Aber was ist das für ein Loch unten im Brötchen drin?
Drückt man rein.
Ne, aber da ist ein Brötchen drin, ein Loch drin.
Manchmal sind da Löcher drin, ja.
Ne, aber häufig sogar.
Ja?
Ich kenne, glaube ich, kein Brötchen ohne Loch von McDonalds.
Sorry.
Ganz kurz, dreht mal die Burger um.
Was?
Dreht mal die Burger von McDonalds um, wir sind da was auf der Spur, glaube ich. Pass auf, Stefan, ich habe ein Wort für dich. Bagel. Nee. Kommen wir da weiter. Ja und nein. Stefan, schau mir in die Augen. Schau mich an. Hast du einen Bagel gegessen? Stefan, schau mich an. Hast du einen Bagel gegessen? Donut.
Hast du einen Donut gegessen?
Nee, es hat ein Loch, aber jetzt ein Schlächtchen.
Aber ist das jetzt eine Verschwörungstheorie von dir, alle Burger haben unten ein Loch?
Ja, ich habe ja keine krasse Verschwörungstheorie.
Gibt es bestimmt eine Facebook-Gruppe dazu, glaube ich, alle Burger haben unten ein Loch, prove me wrong.
Einfach so, 2000 Follower?
Ich musste sehr lachen über die neue Facebook-Gruppe, Christen gegen kernlose Wassermelonen, die jetzt ein Trend war. Ist konsequent, ist konsequent. Sehr konkret, aber auch hier wieder dieses Feindbild gefällt mir eigentlich. Man isst Wassermelonen nur zur Fortpflanzung, deswegen ohne Kerne geht es nicht. Ist nur konsequent eigentlich. Das stimmt schon. Wassermelonen sind schon sehr potent, ne? Ja. Die haben schon ordentlich ... Die haben ordentlich Druck, du, oder? Das kann man schon ... Die haben schon ... Ja, wirklich. Ich meine, wie lange wächst so ein Ding? Wenn du so eine Wassermelonen wegwirfst, kommen da bestimmt Millionen Wassermelonbäume raus.
Ja.
Wie viele Samen hat ein Apfel?
Vier?
Acht?
Fünfzehn.
Das ist ja nichts gegen eine Wassermelone.
Drei Milliarden.
Gar nichts.
Das sind schon viele Kerne, ne?
Das sind zu viele einfach.
Es sind zu viele.
Ob das mal ein grosser Kern war und da hat man das, da wollte man das, da wurde man
gierig.
Das kann schon sein.
Da wurde man gierig und wollte dann die Wassermelone größer züchten, das Fruchtfleisch, und bei einer Kreuzung hat man das Fruchtfleisch größer bekommen, aber leider halt den Kern gesprengt. Es kann gut sein, ja, ich meine es gab eine ganze, also wenn nicht mal wirklich Film, Serienidee, ich überhebe mir so, Also Filmfalls waren, welche historische Figur sollte eine Serie bekommen? Ja, wir kennen alle Hannibal und Marco Polo, Tony Soprano, so man kennt sie alle. Die Person, die ich, wo ich eine Serie haben würde, Mendel. Guter alter Mendel, der gute alte Mendel, der Mönch, der hier die Sachen gekreuzt hat, der in seinem Garten saß und dann so, hier ein Spargel, gekreuze ich mit Huhn, zack, und dann legt er sich ein Jahr lang hin und dann guckt er so, oh, das hat, ja, Staffelpause, da wächst dann alles. Und dann Staffel zwei, alles scheiße. Alles nicht aufgegangen. Aber ich bin Mönch, ich hab keinen Chef, mir egal. Du hast einen Chef. Und was für ein Chef. Sorry. Ah, okay, gut. Du hast einen Chef und der hat Regeln. Strenger Chef. Ja, okay, gut, aber der sagt dann halt so, ja, ich hab jetzt eine Wassermelone, da will ich die Kerne raus machen. Und dann macht er halt die Wassermelone und dann knipst er halt da irgendwas rum und dann kommt da eine Wassermelone.
Das ist wie Knipserei.
Kerne sind raus, aber dafür halt nur ist da Sahne drin.
Und dann sagt er, oh shit, das will ich nicht, jetzt muss ich wieder gucken, wie ich die Sahne da wieder rauskriege,
aber dass die Kernlosigkeit beibehalten bleibt.
So, und das kannst du über sechs Staffeln machen, ohne Locker.
Und dann sein Sohn, Mendelsohn. Ooooooh! Spin-off, schön Spin-off. Stefan versucht seit Monaten verzweifelt den Podcast in so eine Klassikecke zu drängen. Klassikecke. Ich versuche dagegen anzusehen. Ey, nein, also, Florian und ich, wir haben uns mal lange drüber lustig gemacht, wir haben in den letzten Folgen auch drüber gesprochen, wie wär's, wenn man mit klassischen Musikern Interviews führt nach dem Konzert, wie man das mit Fussballern machen würde. Ja, das habe ich mal geträumt, tatsächlich. Das war eine Sketch-Idee, die ich geträumt habe, so wie Frank Elzner das geträumt hat. So, und es ist vor allem... Das will ich wahr. Was, Frank Elzner Wetten? Schüttel nicht den Kopf, das ist wahr! Wie siehst du überhaupt noch Leute? Was willst du denn? Kannst du durch Nebel gucken? Jetzt, ob du das besser weisst. Hau ab jetzt hier raus. Kannst du durch Nebel gucken oder was? Hä? Vielleicht hast du eine Superkraft, dass du durch Nebel gucken kannst. Ich sehe niemanden. Wirklich? Ich sehe wirklich niemanden. Wir sind alle schon weg, Stefan. Sie sind vor 20 Minuten alle gegangen. Oh komm, mach das Licht wieder angemacht. Mach das Licht auf, da will doch keiner sehen. Wenn du das Licht anmachst, dann sehe ich Liverpool nicht mehr. So viele Spieler. Man kann das Ergebnis nicht sehen. Das geht, bummer. Genau, und jedenfalls ist es jetzt relativ viel geworden, weil ich fand das wirklich eine sehr, sehr lustige Fragestellung. Danke. Man sieht selten, also gut geträumt, man geht selten, aber man kann das Lob auch nicht so richtig annehmen, weil du hast ja nicht wirklich aktiv dir überlegt. Das war Traum. Das wurde dir geschenkt. Ja, aber ich war wie Mendel. du bist Mendel. Traum funktioniert ja so, den Tag über denkst du Sachen und im Traum kommt dann alles zusammen. Sehr gut, nee, sehr gut. Wie so ein Staffelfinale. Und wenn du den Tag über die richtigen, es ist wie so ein Shake, du tust den Tag über die richtigen Elemente rein, schüttelst du einmal und dann kriegst du deinen Traum. Wo ist das ein Shake, wie ich vom Münzautobahn stehe und Dinge reinwerfe? Ja, Smoothie oder halt einfach ein Mischgetränk. Langweiliger Shake. Mischgetränk im weitesten Sinne des Wortes. Du tust, mein Gott, das Konzept, dass man Sachen zusammentut und dann mischt, ist nicht so kompliziert. Nee, ich frag mich nur gerade, dann ist meine Staffelfinale immer sehr langweilig. Ich traue immer nur wahnsinnig langweilige Dinge. Ja, weil du nicht die richtigen Sachen in den Shaker reintust. Hör doch mal zu! Ja, ja! Ja, gut! Okay! So, jedenfalls, sehr guter Traum, sehr gute Idee, danke, und deswegen haben wir das vor ein paar Wochen noch mal angeteast und uns hat wirklich ein klassischer Musiker geschrieben, und zwar hat er geschrieben, dass er Klarinette spielt bei den Duisburger Philharmonikern und das war letzten Sonntag und wie es der Zufall sollte, sollte, war ich abends in Duisburg in der Oper. So, und wer hat da gespielt? Unser Hörer hat Klarinette gespielt bei der Duisburger Philharmonik. Und ich fand das wahnsinnig lustig, weil ich mich sehr gefreut habe darüber, dass ich zufällig in dem Publikum sitze, wo ein Podcast-Ufo-Fan tatsächlich abends dann ... Zieh dein T-Shirt an! Ich habe mir einen kleinen Händen-Shirt angezogen. Und er hatte das Podcast-Ufo-T-Shirt an. Ja, war rückblickend unangenehm. Ich habe ihm sogar gesagt, ich habe ihm dann geschrieben, er soll in Akt 3 die Podcast-Ufo-Melodie unterbringen. Hat er nicht gemacht. So viel dazu. Aber ich fand das wirklich wahnsinnig lustig und ich habe ihm gesagt, wir machen das jetzt mit ihm. Wir machen Field-Interviews. Er soll einfach nach jedem Akt kurz schreiben, wie er es fand. Wie er mit seiner Performance zufrieden war, mit der Performance des Teams zufrieden war. Und dann kam auch in der ersten Pause nach Akt eins die erste Nachricht. Welche Oper hast du gesehen? Götterdämmerung. Klar. Von Richard. So, klar. Ja, gut. So, die erste Nachricht kam dann auch pünktlich nach Akt 1. Bin insgesamt ganz zufrieden, am Anfang hat es so wenig gedauert, bis alle drin waren, aber es hat sich dann doch ganz gut eingespielt. Es ist wirklich wie ein Fussballspiel. Bei mir persönlich hat ein Klarinettenblatt, jetzt wird es ein bisschen anders, bei mir persönlich hat ein Klarinettenblatt schlapp gemacht, das konnte ich dann aber rechtzeitig korrigieren. Und ich dachte mir, what, solche Probleme hat man dann im Offensohle? Klarinettenblatt macht schlapp. Genau, also Klarinettenblatt macht schlapp. Wow, das heisst auch seine Biografie. Und dann hat man Klarinettenblatt schlapp gemacht. Ich glaube, das ist, ich dachte auch, ist es ein Sprichwort oder sowas, was man sich erzählt als Klarinettist, ist aber, glaube ich, wirklich die Wahrheit. Spielte jemand Klarinette? Ist es nicht einfach, oh ist das so eine ... Ja genau, aus der letzten Reihe, hat eine Klarinette mitgemacht. Gibt es nicht bei Star Wars in der Kantine sogar Kantine, Kantine, gibt es da nicht sogar einen so einen Alien, der einfach eine Klarinette, Niemand in Space sagt Kantine, der einfach eine Klarinette als Nase hat, also schon so fest Eingachsen. Da gibt's doch so Instrumentenwesen, die ja für den ganzen Tag Klarinette spielen. Ne? Ich glaube schon. Als Fan sollte man den Namen kennen von dem Wesen. Wie heißt der? Weiß nicht. Klarinetto. Oboe. Ich weiß nicht, wie er heißt. Und die Katina-Bench spielt auch nur Fagott. Und die Einheit so ein weirdes Instrument. Aber ist das ein grosses Problem? Also klarinierte Blatt macht schlapp, man kennt es irgendwie, kurz man setzt an zum grossen Solo und du denkst dir, das Blatt macht ein bisschen schlapp, man kennt es schon. Ja, man kennt es, ich glaube es ist wirklich ein Problem, ich glaube du hast oben, beim Saxophon ja auch, ich glaube bei allen Holzbläsern hast du so ein kleines Blättchen, was dann vibriert. Aber ist es nicht so, dass eigentlich nur das Blatt zählt und der Rest ist so Deko? Ja, der Rest ist egal. So von dem Instrument zu dieses ganze, scheissegal. Scheissegal. Du hast da ein Blatt rein und es muss vibrieren, das benetzt du dann mit der Zunge und ich glaube, wenn das durch ist, irgendwann ist einfach zu viel Speichel dran und dann funktioniert es nicht mehr. Krass. Das war jedenfalls ein Problem. Fand ich sehr lustig, dass das irgendwann so ein Problem wird bei einem kleinen Artisten.
Ich dachte, die spielen das komplett souverän runter.
Das ist mit einer Hand, nebenbei auf Instagram oder einfach so.
Da wird er jeden Tag dasselbe Spiels.
Aber er konnte das Problem rechtzeitig korrigieren.
Sehr gut. Aber sehr dank.
Zwischendurch gab es mal ein kleines Konzentrationsloch.
Viel Gähnen, gerade in den letzten Reihen. Aber insgesamt war es gut und es gab sehr viele schöne Momente, fand ich. Das war Akt 1, Gebüt passiert. Ich fühl mich, als wäre ich dabei gewesen. Schon, oder? Gut, es ist ein bisschen echt wie ein Field-Interview, es ist so vage. Es ist so vage wie so ein Field-Interview. Nach Akt zwei kam dann, bei mir lief diesmal etwas entspannter und auch das Material hat besser geschwungen, also eine rein instrumentale Sache bei mir. Insgesamt gab es ein paar kleine Unkonzentriertheiten, aber auch insgesamt gut. Stopp, wenn das bei ihm im zweiten Akt eine rein instrumentale Sache war, was ist es dann sonst? Hast du gesungen in Akt eins? Der Mann spielt ein Instrument. Ja, wieder scheiss instrumentale Sache heute. Also eine rein instrumentale Sache bei mir, hat er geschrieben.
Vielleicht klopfen die sonst noch so mit oder so?
Und die Intonation war bei den Bläsern etwas besser als im ersten Teil.
Sehr gut. Und er wurde sogar gelobt. Ich war sehr stolz. Ich war wirklich, ich dachte mir, das ist total cool.
Moment, wie der wurde gelobt?
Ich habe danach einen Artikel gelesen in der Westfälischen Rundschau und da wurden die Holzbläser gelobt, unter anderem der satte Klang der Klarineppen. Satt, yes, satter Klang, nicht schlecht, Christoph Diddich, aber unser Hörer, mich das total gefreut. Hey, unser Hörer hat einen satten Klang, einmal für Christoph. Großen Applaus für Christoph, satter Klang. Ich finde das ganz toll! Ja, guck mal, unsere Hörer leisten richtig was. Er hat an dem Gelingen dieses tollen, hochkulturellen Abends mitgewirkt. Es klingt einfach gut, ein satter Klang. Er war satten, was ist das Gegenteil davon, was war einfach so ein flacher Klang? Weiss man nicht. Ich weiss nicht genau. Weiss man nicht genau. Aber er wurde nicht persönlich gelobt. Nein, es wurde nicht gesagt, Christoph hat gut gespielt. Die Holzbläser im Allgemeinen. Christoph, Kleidungswahl liest zu wünschen übrig, ob man einen Podcast-Shirt an einem Opernabend tragen sollte. Sei mal dahingestellt, aber sein Klang war satt. Ja, bei uns im Schultheater, wo ich bei dem Oberstufentheater mal mitspielen durfte und Statist sein durfte, wurde in der Zeitung danach jede einzelne Rolle gelobt. Und der letzte Satz war, nur die Statisten wirkten ein bisschen unmotiviert. Unmotiviert? Okay, okay, alles klar, nehme ich mir zu Herzen, Kulturkritiker. Vielleicht hat er nicht verstanden, dass er eine unmotivierte Meute spielen musste. Ja, ich weiss nicht, vor allem ist es so, wenn man dann in eine Gruppe geworfen wird, so die Statisten sind scheiße, wo man sich denkt so, nee, ich höre gerne noch mal jeden einzelnen Statisten so, oder was, vielleicht bin ich ja positiv rausgestochen. Ich weiß es nicht, es war Niederschmettern, war die erste Kritik meines Lebens und unmotiviert. Ja. Aber sie hat auch Recht, also irgendwo, ich war nicht ganz da an dem Abend. Warst du nicht dabei? Nee? Ich war nicht ganz da an dem Abend, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Warst du unmotiviert oder hast du richtig Bock?
Na, ich war motiviert, aber die Scheinwerfer haben mir direkt in die Augen geleuchtet,
von daher ist das schwer …
Das ist für dich jeden Abend ein Problem, wo man auf der Bühne steht.
Es ist schwer motiviert zu bleiben.
Ich weiss nicht, ob ich da noch eine Brille getragen habe, ehrlich gesagt, einfach so
reingelasert haben, ich weiss nicht genau.
Wirklich?
Trägst du …
Ich habe früher als Kinder mir eine Brille getragen, ja.
Warum?
Du hast doch keine Sehschwelle.
Doch, doch, doch. Ja? Ja, ja, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, u Kind, pass auf, als Kind hatte ich eine Brille, weil ich eine Brille gebraucht habe, und dann hat jemand zu mir gesagt, Brillenschlange, und dann hat er gesagt, jetzt hat er mich keine Brille mehr getragen und irgendwie passt es schon. Tatsächlich, und dann habe ich mich mein ganzes Leben so durchgenudelt, weil ich dachte, du weißt ja immer nicht genau, ob du gut genug siehst. Du mogelst dich gerade durch. Ja, und dann dachte ich mir, Moment, stopp, und dann dachte ich mir, bei der Führerscheinprüfung musste man dann zum Augenmeister und der hat dann gesagt, und der hat dann gesagt, und der hat dann gesagt, und der hat dann gesagt, und der, irgendwie, du willst ja nicht dann so mit 10 Prozent und der guckt dich an so, wie haben sie die letzten 10 Jahre überliebt, wie geht das? Sie sehen auf einem Auge gar nichts und auf dem anderen falsch rum. Und auf dem anderen die Folge Simpsons, was ist das? Wie sind Sie hierher gekommen, wie hat das funktioniert? Aber tatsächlich einfach, ich habe viel geraten, aber es hat am Ende funktioniert. Einfach, da habe ich tatsächlich bestanden und ich glaube, habe ich auch mal gehört, dass es so ist, wenn man keine Brille trägt, dann macht das Auge das halt von selber so, irgendwann. Dann muss das Auge halt ein bisschen mehr stemmen. Funktioniert so Wissenschaft eigentlich? Wenn man nichts macht, dann macht es halt von allein. Ja, was soll der... Guck mal, das Auge ist doch hier... Guck mal, jetzt erklär ich dir mal. Ich will keinen Arzt haben, der anfängt mit... Guck mal. So, so wollen wir jetzt gar nicht anfangen. Ist doch so. So wollen wir jetzt gar nicht anfangen, gell? Also, du musst doch... Guck mal, das Auge ist doch so evolutionär darauf ausgebildet, dass es sich anpasst.
So, und wenn es nicht schleisse sieht, dann irgendwann sagt er, oh, drehen wir hier noch ein bisschen, drehen wir da noch ein bisschen, dann passt es schon wieder. Da wärst du dann sofort tot, wenn du nicht richtig siehst. Ich war mal beim Augentest und dann haben die aber vorher das Blatt halt liegen lassen, wo man drauf gucken muss. Und ich habe mir die Reihen gemerkt und dann dachte ich mir, wie irrational das gerade ist, weil ich will ja besser sehen, ich will eine Brille, die perfekt auf meine Augen angepasst ist, deswegen bin ich ja hier. Ich bin ja hier, um eine neue Brille zu haben, weil ich schlechter sehe, aber ich will diesen fucking Test bestehen. Und dann habe ich mir diese Reihe gemerkt und dann habe ich immer gesagt, ich habe das Rätsel aufgelöst, weil sie dachte, wow, du hast tausend Prozent Seekraft. Ja, das dachte sie will wahrscheinlich übersehen und übersehen. Du siehst besser als der Weisskopf-Seeadler. Und dann habe ich es aufgelöst und habe gesagt, nee, ich habe es mir gemerkt. Was war die Reaktion darauf? Puh? Ernsthaft, Puh war die Reaktion? Puh, puh. Nee, ich glaubaah, hab ich geahnt. Aaaaaaah, Tietze! Du musst ja auch spielen. Du musst ja auch spielen. Du kannst ja nicht A, B, G, H. Du musst ja in der letzten Reihe schon so tun, als siehst du es nicht richtig. Ja, A, was ist das? Ich kann mir wirklich keine denkbare Reaktion vorstellen, wie die Augenärztin auch reagiert. Ich weiß auch nicht, weil das ist schon länger her. Einfach so, na, Herr Tüte, na na na. Das dritte Mal heute. Dann holen wir mal die schweren, haha. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, wenn ich so eine Szene schreiben müsste. Hat kein Bestes gewesen, wenn sie das geändert hätte, wenn sie das neunjährig hat, ich hätte das nicht gesehen und hätte selbstbewusst gesagt A, B, G, Z, D und sie hätte gesagt, what? Da sind nicht mal Buchstaben drauf. Sie sollen mir sagen, ob es ein Elefant oder eine Giraffe ist. Dann kriegst du eine Augenbinde. Das ist ihre Brille, Herr Tietze. Zwei Augenklappen. Das bringt gar nichts mehr. Wie so ein doppelter Pirat. Zwei Augenklappen halt. Das wirdix. Doppelter Pirat, das klingt irgendwie schmutzig.
Hä?
Das klingt irgendwie so in der ganz...
Ne, wir machen nachher im Hotelzimmer schön noch einen doppelten Piraten.
Alles klar.
Aber nicht so wie letztend. Das war Tat B.
Ja, ja, ja. Erstmal Seemann im Nebel und dann doppelter Pirat.
Ja.
Wenn du durchhierst.
Ich kann von gestern nach noch nicht wieder hören, richtig.
Obwohl auch so wehre Beschreibung, wo man nicht genau weiß, was passiert ist. Ja, meine Schulter ist noch ganz taub. Hm. Hm. Was passiert da gerade? Filmst du uns gerade? Das habe ich dich erwischt, da habe ich dich erwischt. Durch den Nebel gesehen. Das ist auch so. Wenn man sich so einen Film anschaut, der abgefilmt wurde im Kino, und dann so, ja der Film war ganz gut, aber alle fünf Minuten fragt jemand, filmen Sie gerade? Fragt Tom Cruise, filmst du gerade? Aber tatsächlich würde ich so ein Video gerne über Instagram sehen, in Instagram Stories, wo jemand plötzlich auf der Bühne sagt, filmst du ja gerade? Weil das wird dann immer nicht hochgeladen. Das laden wir bitte hoch gleich. Ja, kannst du bitte... Nee, jetzt nicht faken. Wo sind wir denn hier? Wir sind authentisch. Kannst du bitte die Story direkt danach so machen, als würdest du von Security so rausgezerrt werden? Ja. Ich hab nichts gemacht, ich bin unschuldig. Das wäre ganz geil. Können wir das kurz mal faken? Wir brauchen zwei Freiwillige. Zwei Freiwillige, das ist auch so ein deutsches Ding. Niemand sagt auf. Du mit der Kappe. Du mit der Kappe, komm mal kurz. Mach mal kurz einen rauszerren. Ja, sehr gut. Mach mal kurz einen, wo auch noch einen. Sehr gut. Du auch, sehr gut, beide mit der Kappe. Ich meinte den hinter dir mit der Kappe. Okay, stopp, okay. Wie machen wir das jetzt? Warte, stopp, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, hat das jetzt funktioniert? Ah, das Moment, ganz kurz. Leute, stopp, stopp, stopp.
Ja, dann haben wir es jetzt verkackt, wenn wir auf der Bühne, ey, ey, ey, stopp rufen.
Hey, stopp ist nur ein Scherz.
Okay, ganz kurz, kannst du kurz sagen, wie du heisst, die Filmerin?
Äh, Jasmin.
Ah, okay, hallo.
Ich habe Performed in der Theater AG.
Okay, okay, darum ging es jetzt gerade gar nicht.
Und was sagen die Kritiker, was haben die Kritiker gesagt?
Hey, du kannst nicht das Macking-off-Filmen dahinter.
Das geht so nicht.
Okay, stopp, Leute, Konzentration jetzt. Setz dich noch mal hin.
Nee, du kannst doch nicht stehen, dann weiss doch jeder, dass das gefägt ist.
Warum zeigst du ihm den ...
Stopp, kannst du dich noch mal hinsetzen und das dann noch mal filmen.
Wenn du stehst, merkt jeder, dass das gefägt ist. So, hinsetzen, wir imitieren ein normales Gespräch, dann filmst du, nein, noch nicht filmen, wir imitieren ein normales Gespräch, dann kommst du auf die Idee, ey Bayern, eure Schüler waren mal clever, was ist jetzt passiert? Kritik wird vernichten in der Mannheimer Post zu diesem Abend. Wir imitieren ein normales Gespräch. Du fängst an uns zu filmen, wir reagieren, ich reagiere sauer, ich sag, hey, was filmst du da eigentlich gerade? Durch den Nebel gesehen, was ich gerade für den Bullshit glaubt habe, und dann kommt, dann steht, ihr müsst ihr wieder, warum wird ihr wieder hingesetzt? Nein, nein, nein, das ist doch realistisch, stopp, genau so ist doch realistisch. Aber Security, dann sitzt ist doch nicht im Publikum versteckt. Ja doch, das sind Undercover-Security-Leute. Das gibt's, klar. Fast war der Punkt, wo ihr gesagt habt, das wird nichts, wir setzen uns wieder hin. Nein, nein, nein, das ist schon gut. Das ist schon gut. Kannst du bitte von drei runter zählen, dann fängst du an zu filmen. Ja, das machen wir jetzt mal nicht. Wir faken hier gar nichts, okay? Also bitte, zieh uns hier nicht mit runter. Das sind diese Schauspielerinnen, diese Theaterschauspielerinnen, wir wissen alles besser. Ihr lebt nur für den Statisten, okay? Ohne uns werdet ihr gar nichts! Ja genau!
Ja!
Wir sind alle Statisten.
Ich hab performt.
Okay, du zählst runter, dann fangen wir an und in ein paar Sekunden sagst du ihr, dass sie aufhören soll.
Und dann springt ihr auf und zerrt sie raus, okay?
Seid so brutal, wie ihr möchtet.
Sie kann sich jetzt nicht wehren, sonst würde sie die Aufnahme ruinieren. Alles klar, dann gibt alles Jungs, okay? Zehn Euro auf sie, gut. Okay, bist du bereit? Okay, ich soll unterzählen. Schwierig, ich habe in Bayern eine Kunde. Ohhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh Jedenfalls Baseball habe ich bis heute nicht ganz verstanden, da hast du halt Innings und ich habe bis heute nicht genau verstanden, was eigentlich...
Ja, ja, wie viele hat...
What the fuck, filmst du da gerade oder was? Ach komm, Alter, du kannst jetzt nicht filmen. Könnt ihr euch mal darum kümmern? Ach komm. Du kannst doch nicht einfach filmen. Was denn... Hey. Sehr gut. Schmeiß sie raus!
Jedenfalls weiss ich mich heute nicht ganz innings. Was sind innings? Innings vorbei.
Wunderte, wie viele gibt's neun innings? Kann man innings gewinnen?
Und so wurde der Faschismus geboren.
Runde Nummer zwei aus München, jetzt schaffen wir es aber, jetzt läuft's.
Ihr könnt sie wieder zurückbringen. Ihr wart fantastisch. Ihr wart fantastisch.
Ihr wart einen Applaus für unsere drei Darsteller, fantastisch. Sehr gut.
Und jetzt wäre wichtig, jetzt beginnt ja eigentlich erst die Arbeit. Jetzt musst du dir überlegen, eine reißerische Überschrift überlegen, wie du das Ganze hochlädst. Ja, Skandal! Eklat beim Podcast-Ufo auftritt oder sowas. Das kriegst du schon hin. Das kriegst du schon hin und dann müssen wir es alle retweeten.
Wir nicht, weil das wird ein bisschen küsselig.
Und dann, ähm...
Ja, aber die neben ihr hat das alles gefilmt jetzt, ne?
Ja, das kann ich dann auflösen in einem Monat bei der Bild.de.
Die Fokusgeschichte einfach so.
Alles Luke und Trug.
Bild.de, Skandal, nur ein Fake und dann wird dein Video kommen.
Skandal, es war gar kein Skandal.
Ja.
Baffs!
Und dann hat er mich aufgeregt. Die Leute sind wahnsinnig wütend. Schocker! Schocker! So, Tottenham. Ihr ist ein Tor gefallen vorhin, oder? 1-0? 1-0 Ajax. Oh, traurig, sehr traurig für alle. Weiß nicht. Ajax sagt mir gar nichts. Ist das eine Stadt Stadt, ist das Universität? Amsterdam. Apex. Apex Technical. Ja, genau. Wer sagt sie ihm? Nee, es ist da, der wo immer gegenüber, da sehen wir doch immer, haben wir Louis C. Kay gesehen, da haben wir Chris Rock gesehen, Ricky Deves, gegenüber von der Ajax Arena in Amsterdam. Ah, okay, krass. Vielleicht habe ich sogar so einen Bären davon. Du hast wahrscheinlich einen Bären. So einen kleinen Ajax-Bären. Und du hast die Währung, wie du eine Arena, in der du damit bezahlen kannst. Die schönen Munden. Munden. Munden. In Ajax, ach sag ich schon, wir sind schon beim Ajax, in Amsterdam gibt es diese coolen Parallelwährungen in Arenen. Ja. Hört euch Folge 23 an. Wisst ihr was, ich habe eine gute Idee für eine tolle Quiz-Sendung, und zwar, das gibt es in England und es ist die beste Sendung der Welt. Du hattest die Idee. Ja, na ja. Florentin Will Endloved, Skandal. Ich hatte, ach Gott, Eclat. Was genau ist der Unterschied zwischen dem Eclat und dem Skandal? Eclat. Oder ist es nur der Mitte... Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Eclat und Eclat? Ich weiß es nicht genau. Der Eclat. Das wäre einfach mal... Das wäre geil. Irgendein Bildreporter wartet da seit Jahren drauf und sagt, Leute, ich habe die Überschrift... Der Artikel ist schon geschrieben. Ja, der Sandalen-Skandal und der Eclair-Eclair. Und dann hören sie mit der Zeitung auf und sagen, besser wird es einfach nicht mehr. Das war's. In England gibt es die Quiz-Sanung University Challenge und da treten englische Universitäten gegeneinander an und die sind so unfassbar schlau, das ist wirklich unfassbar, du kannst dir die Sendung angucken und die Sendung ist unglaublich trocken, da gibt es ein Live-Publikum, das Live-Publikum applaudiert am Anfang zwölf Sekunden, also ganz kurz, und heute die Teams und dann ist die gesamte Show und am Ende applaudieren sie nochmal, fünf Sekunden und dazwischen nichts und das ist die trockenste Sendung der Welt. Schaut mal auf YouTube, University Challenge. Aber weil die alle Bock haben, jetzt Quiz zu bekommen. Ja, weil das ist einfach so ein No-Bullshit-Quiz, einfach kein Spaß. Die haben wirklich dann und die haben dann so die krassesten Sachen irgendwie, wenn man welche elementaren Zeichen hintereinander der Reihenfolge ihrer Buchstaben wählt, dann welches Land kommt dann raus, das im Zweiten Weltkrieg nicht an den Kampfhandlungen beteiligt wurde, und die so, ja, ihr Polen, keine Ahnung, und du guckst dir das an und denkst so, ja, das hätte ich auch gewusst, wenn ich ein bisschen länger nachdenken könnte, so. Du schaust es einfach an, du bist einfach völlig ratlos, völlig ratlos. Und fühlst dich gleich danach. Aber es ist gut, es finde ich, es ist eine Quelle von Patriotismus, die wir noch nicht ausgeschöpft haben, Universitäten. Wir spielen immer Städte gegeneinander beim Fussball, aber ich glaube, es wäre viel besser, wenn wir so dieses akademische Intellektuelle hervorkehren würden und unsere Universitäten gegeneinander antreten lassen würden, in so Quiz-Sachen. Weil dann würde man sagen, ah, die sind erfolgreich, weil sie klug sind und nicht wie die Fussballer. Ja. Die auch gut sind, die sind auch super. Mega gut. Aber, also denkt man, geht mal einfach mit dem Gedanken mal nach Hause und überlegt euch mal, falls euch irgendjemand von ProSieben hier fragt, was will zum Fernsehen sehen. Ich denke, das ist die ganze Konkurrenz, die ganze Ivy League Konkurrenz auch in den USA. Ja. Das ist etwas Gutes, glaube ich. In Deutschland hat man das gar nicht. Nee, dann will man sich übertrumpfen, aber auf einem intellektuellen Niveau, nicht nur auf so Sportwettkämpfe. Ja, irgendwie da gibt es da nichts, und welche Universität will man unbedingt? Köln? Keine Ahnung, ich weiß es wirklich nicht, ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung. Wir müssen stolzer auf unsere Universitäten werden, so das sage ich jetzt einfach mal nur hier in den Raum. Okay, okay, ist gesagt, gut, so zwei Leute sind dabei, reicht, reicht für eine Partei, reicht schon, reicht, viele Leute reichen.
Ne, das stimmt schon. Ich weiss nicht genau, warum gibt es das in Deutschland nicht. Universitäten sind auch kleiner alt und ich würde auch vor allem mal vorschlagen, wir ziehen um aus diesen 80er Jahre, 70er Jahre Gebäuden, schön in so Burgen, wie das in den USA halt ist. Ja, das stimmt schon. Wir haben viele Burgen, wenn man die Mosel langfährt, über eine Burg, da eine Burg, da ein Schloss und dann schön einfach die Universitäten da einpflanzen, in so altehrwürdige Gebäude, da will man auch lieber sein. Es stimmt schon, wir machen zu wenig aus unseren Burgen, es stimmt schon, früher super wertvoll, heute nichts mehr, Hüpfburgen, das ist eine Schande, das ist eine Schande für unser Land, wir machen uns lustig über unsere schönsten Bauwerke, das ist lächerlich, man kann auch eine Wahl nehmen, Hüpfwahl, kannst du auch machen. Nee, Hüpfburg. Ja, das ist lächerlich so. Jedes Kind wächst auf mit dem Bild, dass eine Burg weich ist und man bricht sich auch mal so einen Knöchel. Aber mehr auch nicht. Früher war es anders. Ja, das ist, ja. Vor allem, ich verstehe auch nicht, warum es in Deutschland keine coole Serie gibt, die man mit diesen Burgen was macht. So, etwas wie Game of Thrones, das wäre halt total gut drehbar in Deutschland. Aber halt nur in Burgen einfach die ganze Zeit. Ja, die müssen uns alle CGI nachbauen. Guck mal ein Drache, aber man bleibt immer nur innerhalb der Burg und ooooh, jetzt hat er den abgeschossen. Ooooooh, guck dir das an. Da passiert um die Erzählen Game of Thrones nach. Zurück zur Zofe Zofe. Oh, Starbucks-B wieder was machen. Ich will mal... Und die Klarinette. Christoph war eine Klarinette. Das Klarinettensolo braucht eigentlich wieder guter Song.
Warum diese Serie?
Ja, wir müssen mal wieder was machen.
Hast du mal Lust, was zu machen?
Ja, lass mal was machen.
So eine Webserie oder so.
Ja, das ist eine kleine Webserie auf dem YouTube-Kanal.
Wir haben ja noch ein paar rumliegen.
Wir haben noch einen YouTube-Kanal rumliegen.
Wir haben noch drei YouTube-Kanäle rumliegen.
Stimmt, wir haben immer wieder die Musik.
Ja, ich fühle euren Applaus in meinem Herzen, lässt mich aber trotzdem das Passwort nicht einfallen. Da ist, vielen Dank fürs Herzblut, vielen Dank fürs Interesse, aber grossgeschrieben, kleingeschrieben, ich weiss es einfach nicht mehr, es ist einfach nicht mehr da. Soll ich mal kurz Kritik üben? Dankeschön an Funk, die übrigens nicht mehr bereit sind, die Rechnung für Gute Arbeit Originals
bei Soundcloud zu bezahlen, weshalb jetzt die Folgen gelöscht werden.
Oh, von Gute Arbeit Impro.
Kurz mal hier vor Publikum, es sehr einfach machen, aber das ist wirklich eine Sauerei.
Du hast gerade gesehen, wie sehr gewaltbereit unsere Zuschauerschaft ist, wie schnell sie sind,
irgendjemanden aufzustacheln.
Ja, wo ist das Headquarter von Funk?
Wo ist das?
Auf nach Mainz! Mainz! Wo ist Mainz? Sie sind in so einer Burg? Ins Ufo-Mobil! Wir müssen die Funk-Burg einnehmen. Ja, das gute... ja. Ja, gut. Die bezahlen es nicht. Aber wir bezahlen die doch. Ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Kannst du nicht bei deinem Gema-Zettel draufschreiben? Ja, zahle ich gerne, aber bitte spezifisch für den Soundcloud-Account von Gute Arbeit im Pro. Ja, ich weiss nicht, ob das geht. Ich weiss es auch nicht. Es funktioniert nicht. Gut, lassen wir es. Lassen wir es. Und sonst so, hast du sonst irgendwas erlebt? Blumen gegossen? Ich habe Blumen gegossen, ich habe Bilderrahmen gekauft. Ja, Gottauft. Ja, Gott. Ich habe wirklich einen Bilderrahmen gekauft. Für dein riesiges Bild? Nee, kleines Bild. Ja. Aber das bedeutet mir sehr viel. Aber findest du einen Bilderrahmen für dein riesiges Bild, Stefan? Die Zeit hat ja ein wandfüllendes, riesiges Bild. Ja. Für alle, die es nicht wissen. Nee, es braucht keinen Rahmen. Das ist eine Leinwand. Aha. Da braucht man nicht unbedingt einen Rahmen. Außerdem kostet das... Vor allem, ich habe für ein kleines habe ich mir einen Bilderrahmen gekauft und ich dachte mir, ich will so einen schönen Rahmen, so ein bisschen so einen ausgefallenen Rahmen, so aus Holz, vielleicht mit Gold, vielleicht sogar was, so schöne alte Rahmen haben, so alte, coole Bilder haben im Museum, so einen schönen Rahmen, ich dachte mir, der kann doch nicht so teuer sein, wenn man den irgendwo kauft. Bin dann ein extra grosses Rahmengesch gefahren, weil ich dachte, das war ein großes Missverständnis, ein großes leckeres Missverständnis erstmal. Google, wo ist dein nächster Rahmen? Dann bin ich da wieder raus und dann bin ich in ein Bilderrahmengeschäft gefahren. Rahmen. Das war sehr lecker. Dann bin ich in ein großes Bilderrahmengeschäft gefahren. Wo auch viele sehr verwirrte Menschen waren. Ja, aber das war wirklich, weil ich dachte, die haben dann die Auswahl. Und die haben bestimmt auch billige Varianten von dem Bilderrahmen, den ich brauchte. Und dann kam ich zu so einem, dann hat die so einen grossen Tresen gehabt, so eine sehr alte Frau. Die war so ein bisschen urig. Wow, das einzige bayerische Wort, das er heute gelernt hat. Er weiss nicht, was es bedeutet, aber er setzt es ein. Na ja, so gemütlich alt, alt gemütlich, eine urige alte Frau. Und die kam dann nachher, hat so grosse Brillengläser auf der Nase, sitzt und kam zu mir, hat sich dann an diesen Tresen gestellt, hat das Bild angeguckt und hat gesagt, was machen wir denn da? Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, das würde ich Ihnen nicht sehr gerne, wo ist der fuck, wie lange kann das denn fallen? Und dann habe ich ihr gesagt, ja, ich würde gerne hier einen für einen Bilderrahmen haben. Ich habe mir etwas Besonderes vorgestellt, da hat sie gesagt, hey, ich habe da was. Ich fühle das. Sie wollte gar nicht hören, was ich zu sagen hatte. Da dachte ich mir, gut, sie hat Erfahrung, sie arbeitet im Bilderrahmgeschäft seit ungefähr 120 Jahren, sie wird ja offensichtlich wissen, was dazu passt.
Hat mir dann so einen Schmetterlingskasten gebracht, wo man das kennt, wenn so ausgestopfte Schmetterlinge da drin sitzen. So kann man auch Bilder cool ausstellen. Fand ich halt sehr speziell und dann haben sie halt diesen grossen Schmetterlingskasten hingestellt und wollte halt mein Bild da reinsetzen und dann habe ich gefragt,
das sieht ganz gut aus, wie viel kostet das denn? Dann hat sie gesagt, ja, 700 Euro. Und ich habe gesagt, da, ne, ne, vielleicht kein Schmetterlingskasten. Moment, aber das war ein Kasten, wo man das Bild reintut, oder was? Reintut und dann kommt vorne drauf, dann ist halt so sehr viel Luft und dann kommt oben drauf noch eine Glasscheibe. Da ist das so ein Kasten an der Wand, was man nicht unbedingt will. Ja. Und vor allem nicht für 700 Euro. Die wartet wahrscheinlich den ganzen Tag auf irgendeinen Trottel, dem sie diesen Kasten nicht verkaufen kann. Ja, und dann hat sie einen neuen Rahmen gebracht und der war wirklich genau das, was ich gesucht habe. Perfekt, ein schöner Rahmen, nicht zu schlicht, nicht zu viel, kein Schmetterlingsrahmen, hat ihn drangesetzt und ich habe gesagt, ja, der ist super und sie gesagt, nee der passt gar nicht und legt ihn weg. Und dann Ende vom Lied war, dass sie entschieden hat, welcher Rahmen auf mein Bild passt. Es war so ein ganz altes Geschäft und ich konnte nicht widersprechen, am Ende musste ich wirklich ohne Scheiss für 200 fucking Euro einen Rahmen kaufen. Das war die billigste Variante, auf die ich gekommen bin, mit ihrem Einverständnis zu sein. Und der Rahmen, der mir gefallen hat, hat 60 Euro gekostet. Und sie hat gesagt, nee, das passt nicht zu ihm. Aber du kannst dieser alten, urigen Frau ja nicht sagen, wollen sie mich verarschen? Ich hätte gerne lieber diesen reinen Rahmen. Du kannst nur den nehmen, den sie dir erlaubt. Einfach so. Ja, die hat mir so einen Vordergehalten, wie die Bilderrahmen suchen sich ja das Bild aus. Und ich hab gesagt, aber warum müssen es denn die teuersten Bilderrahmen? Warum muss es der Bilderrahmen mit der Phönix-Feder drin sein? Ja, exakt. Es war wie bei Ollivanders Lagen. Ja, ja, wo dann ein Bilderrahmen wackelt. Super ärgerlich. Ja, ja. Ist Ollivander auch so einer, der dann immer die teuren verkauft? Ja, das ist doch einfach so. Bullshit von wegen, sucht sich ein Zauer sucht sich den... Hät gerne hier den aus Plastik. Der passt nicht zu Ihnen. Der passt nicht zu Ihnen. Ich habe hier dieses Elfenbein mit Phoenix-Feder drin. Und dann unter dem Tisch hat er so einen Buzzer, wo so ein Lichtstrahl kommt. Ja, genau. Und von unten so Wind. Was kostet der? Der kostet 2000 Pfund. Probieren Sie mal aus. Ja, der Zauberstab sucht sich den Zauberer aus. Und dann unterm Tisch und ... knick, knack, nebelt.
Ich glaube, Ollivander war ein richtiges Arschloch.
Richtiges, abgezocktes Arschloch.
Richtiges, aber uriges Arschloch.
Uriges Arschloch.
Sehr urig, einer der urigsten Charaktere im Harry Potter-Universum, muss man tatsächlich sagen.
Das hat mich super ärgerlich.
Aber ist es nicht so ein bisschen schade, dass nicht der Künstler oder die Künstlerin selber entscheidet, welcher Rahmen es ist? Weil das ist ja eben schon ein Teil davon. Manchmal schaue ich mir Bilder an im Museum und denke mir, oh man, alter, Koch, Rembrandt, ey, was ist das denn für ein Rahmen, was ist das denn für ein scheiß Rahmen, einfach so. Ich meine, malen kann er, aber Rahmen, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi. Aber ist das nicht, da geht gar nix. Weil er immer so Hello-Kitty-Rahmen hat, so sehr spezielle Rahmen. Oh, Picasso, komm schon, ey, die letzten fünf Meter, den Rahmen, da hast du es noch versaut. Ich hatte eine, haben wir in New York gesehen, in so einer Ausstellung, da war dann so ein, das ärgert mich bis heute, so ein Bilderrahmen und das Bild bestand aus lauter Punkten und der Bilderrahmen, da waren dann auch Punkte drauf. So als würde das Bild so über den Bilderrahmen gehen. Hat mich wütend gemacht, habe mich da wie ich vor diesem Bild, dachte mir, willst du mich verarschen, was soll das denn für ein Scheiß sein? Das hat bestimmt vom Künstler dann auch. Ja, aber na, weiß ich nicht genau, vielleicht war das dann auch so eine urige Frau, die gesagt hat, ja, da kann man ein paar Punkte drauf. Da kann man ein paar Punkte drauf machen, ja. Du bist als Künstler einfach nicht selber in der Lage dazu, zu bestimmen, wie das rezipiert wird. Sie wäre gerne Künstlerin und hat sich aber halt diesen Rahmenberuf ausgesucht. Ist ja irgendwo falsch abgewogen. Und will sich halt da selbst verwirklichen, auf meine Kosten. Ja, ja. Ist einfach irgendwo in der Akademie falsch abgewogen. Einmal so einen Rahmenkurs gegangen und irgendwann hast du dann den Rahmenabschluss. Super ärgerlich. Und dann wie, Rahmen? Jetzt habe ich diesen sauteuren, potthässlichen Rahmen. Ich finde es einfach so gut, dass du so viel Geld für Kunst ausgibst und jedes seiner Bilder hasst. Einfach das Bild, ich dachte es sei kleiner, ich hasse es. Es ist viel zu gross, es hat einen furchtbaren Rahmen. Wir mussten einen für 200 Euro Lastwagen mieten, das Bild mal ich, aber der Rahmen ist hässlich, ich hasse es einfach. Einfach so das wütendste Museum aller Zeiten. Stefan Tietze sitzt wütend zu Hause. Das Museum ist okay, aber die Führungen sind halt sau wütend und cholerisch. Ich hasse dieses Bild, Alba. Und du hast ja auch noch so viele Spiegel in deiner Wohnung, dann siehst du die alle doppelt und dreifach. Ich hab nicht keinen einzigen Spiegel im Bart. Ich habe tatsächlich auch nur einen Spiegel im Bart und letztens wollte ich meine Hose sehen. Unmöglich. Ja, Schuhe. Unmöglich. Schuhe muss ich immer so angucken. Wie der letzte Depp stehst du dann wirklich todesmutig auf der Badewanne und denkst dir einfach, ich habe viele von diesen Notarzt-Serien geschaut, die fangen exakt so an. Mit Leuten, die keine Spiegel haben. Und dann zack rutschte ab, irgendwie Lendenbruch, zack, irgendwie Bein raus. Lendenbruch? Und dann, ja, keine Ahnung, dann rufen wir einen Notarzt. Dann sagt sie, ich wollte meine Hose sehen. Dann will ich mal sehen, wie du noch einen Notarzt rufst. Ja, aaa, hea, hea, he da, he jo. Es funktioniert nicht, aber tatsächlich, ich habe einen kleinen Ausflug gemacht, ich war in Berchtesgaden. Berchtesgaden? Berchtesgaden in den Bergen und da gibt es so einen Wasserfall und da spricht die ganze Stadt drüber und da gibt es so einen Wasserfall und der fällt immer in, Achtung, wir lernen ein neues Wort heute und zwar, wenn ein Wasserfall in ein Stein, sagen wir mal Stein, Stein, Stein, Stein, Wir vergessen andere Hör streicht mal Stein, in einem Steinsgedöns und dann fließt es aus dem, stellt euch so einen stufenweisen Wasserfall. Kaskade. Und wie heißt das Becken, in das der Wasserfall fließt, von dem aus es aber noch weiter fließt? Gumpen. Gumpen, genau, die Gumpen! Sehr gut, wunderbar, haben wir einen Spot, nein, Gumpen, sehr gut, da wartet er sein ganzes Leben drauf. Wenn du so einen Zettel hinter seinen Stuhl gelegt hast, wo du sagst, bei Minute 35 rufst du rein, Gumpen. Jonas, willst du wirklich Gumpen studieren? Ja, es ist meine Leidenschaft. Und tatsächlich, die sind so ausgespült, dass die halt wie die krasseste Badewanne der Welt sind. Die sind halt ultra glatt, weil da halt seit Jahrtausenden das Wasser durchspült. Und da sind jetzt so Touristen, sind da reingefallen, wollten da baden und die kamen nicht mehr raus. Weil es so glatt war und es ist so glitschig und du kommst nicht mehr raus. Und irgendwann denkst du dir wow. Und warum spricht da jetzt die ganze Stadt drüber? Weil du bist halt so, es ist halt so von ha, plansch, plansch, plansch, ich gehe raus, wow, ich komme hier nicht mehr raus. Ja, bin ich in der Therme. Panik, irgendwann, du hast irgendwann keine Kraft mehr und kommst da nicht mehr raus, beide gestorben. Beide gestorben? Beide tot, ja, ist wirklich so. Und das Schlimmste ist, sie wusste wahrscheinlich nicht mehr, worin sie gerade sterben. Ja genau, ja ja, das ist das Schlimmste. Was passiert hier, wenn ich ein Wort dafür hätte? Und diese Horrorquallen? Damn you, Wasserbassarbecken! Jeder weiss, das Kind weiss, dass man nicht in Gumpen geht. Aber hätten die nicht ein gefährlicheres Wort dafür ausdecken können?
Ich denke mir auch Gumpen, das ist so ein Wort, wo man einfach gerne reinspringt und so Gumpen-Auli so. Ey, sieh dir heute doch schönen Gumpen-Sack. Und auch der Pfarrer bei der Beerdigung so, was muss?
Alessandro, du hast schon okay. Aber auf jeden Fall.
Tom war erst 16 Jahre alt, doch ein Gumpen.
Entschuldigung, musste ihm das Leben nehmen. Viel zu früh ist er gestorben, er ist mit seinem besten Freund, Karl, der war erst 12, in den Gumpen baden gegangen. Aber auch die Eltern von in der ersten Reihe, müssen sie das Lachen Ihnen war kein, Ihnen war kein Abenteuer zu gefährlich, sie liessen sich nie lumpen, doch sie sprangen in die Gumpen. Sie wollten was trinken und sind mit den beiden Humpen ohne sich lumpen zu lassen, ab in den Gumpen. Ja, nee wollte ich jetzt nur mal ganz kurz sagen, falls ihr unterwegs seid, passt auf. Passt höllisch auf. Oder habt dieses weisse Pulver von den Kletterleuten dabei, damit ihr trockene Finger, trockene Finger, hier der läuft da vorbei, ich krieg einen Oscar-Jepenner, zack, hat er hier mit seinem Magnesium-Fänger. Verrückt in diesem Gumpen! Ja, ich glaub nicht. Ich weiss es auch nicht genau, aber höllisch aufpassen, Freunde. Der Tod lauert an jeder Ecke. Das war ein sehr guter Tipp. Schönen Abend noch, haut rein. Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, das war ein sehr guter Tipp zum Schluss. Keine Angst vor Gumpen, habt Angst vor Gumpen. Das ist einfach meine Botschaft an euch. Ihr kriegt das hin. Gibt es schon die ersten Reaktionen auf das Fälschungsvideo? Hast du ihn hochgeladen? Nein, er ist noch nicht hochgeladen. Wir brauchen noch das Erbscheidungsmuster mit euch, das war hochgeladen. Ah, clever, aber das sollt ihr kriegen. Es gab heute ein grosses Hinter der Bühne, kam er mal the Scenes, boah hier gab's so ein Eklat, ich sag's euch, ein Skandal, es war schon Eklat, weil das Merch kam nicht. Und der kam auch nicht! Der Backdrop kam nicht. Der kam nicht, Stunde bevor es losgeht, der Backdrop war nicht da. Weil, und wir waren schon beide nervös, was machen wir, müssen wir den allen Poster schenken, was machen und Gott sei Dank nicht. Also wir sind jetzt am Merchstand, ihr Trottel. Gatting, gatting, gatting. Nein, es ist jetzt tatsächlich, Gott sei Dank noch alles gekommen, es gibt alles, wir haben den Merchstand Gott sei Dank noch aufbauen können, und es gibt das Backdrop, was einen guten Job gemacht hat. Wir haben jetzt noch eine Show in Leipzig, vielleicht versteigern Vielleicht versteigern wir unseren Backdrop. Der hat viel mitgemacht, der ist durch ganz Deutschland geflogen. Und vielleicht, wir wissen nicht, was wir dem machen. Das Management ruft, schmeißt die Arme in die Lüfte und sagt, auf gar keinen Fall, dass Backdrops versteigern. Okay, sorry. Ansonsten, wir sind gleich noch am Merchstand, falls ihr ein Foto mit uns machen wollt, immer gerne. Ansonsten, vielen Dank an München, ihr wart fantastisch. an münchen das war ich ganz gut macht's gut wir heben ab Vielen Dank.